We are live ladies and gentlemen,
but you knew that you,
you can hear us.
We need to come up with a better way to
start these fucking things.
You have to have like we have you all
heard.
Yeah.
I think that's like trademark shit up.
We'd have to pay buffer.
It's like subsidies.
What if we did backwards live?
We are.
Then we would have to owe Yoda money.
We're fucked.
If we do fucked.
If we don't.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by kerosene games.
A kerosene games is one of our newest
sponsors and I'm.
One of the things that me and brian sort
of committed to when we started doing
this podcast was to make sure that we
didn't ever get advertised by anybody
that we don't believe in.
You know,
just don't,
don't just take someone's money if you
think the product is dog shit or if you
would never use it yourself.
And uh,
so this.
So when we add somebody like kerosene
games,
it's,
it's kind of a big deal for us.
They just seem like a really cool
company.
They are,
first of all,
they're trying to make really bad ass
games for iphones and IPADS and then
coming out with android devices most
likely in January,
possibly February for so those nights
like,
which can be really incredible.
Galaxy s three are those,
the Samsung galaxy note to the huge ones
now you could,
um,
play the games on them and they're
really bad ass and they're designed
specifically for these sort of
touchscreen devices,
very intuitive controls,
which is like a lot better than a game
that you would get that like made to a
pc first,
but then sort of poured it over.
So these,
uh,
it's just,
a much better way to do it.
And Kerosene Games is concentrating on
doing just that.
And they're,
they're super like high quality,
beautiful looking.
It's really fun.
The first game is called Blade slayer.
It's like some dude who's like a bionic
cowboy character.
Hey,
returns from years at war and you just
kicking ass.
Okay.
That's basically what it is.
Fucking with this ridiculous storylines.
Storylines all written.
But,
and don't forget if you have like,
like,
um,
like my sister just got an Ipad,
my Stepdad and my dad,
they all got ipads now.
I wouldn't do it with my dad or my
Stepdad made my dad.
But like you can gift apps.
If you go to the APP store,
you can just send it.
Like if you have a cousin that just got
an Ipad,
he wants a game right now that is
fucking ninety nine cents and it's a
good game.
And guess what?
Your cousin will freak out if it's first
ipad or a new ipad.
It's ninety nine cents until the 29th of
December.
And then I believe they're going to,
it's going to go back to,
it's only two 99 after that,
which is crazy.
But it is,
you're right,
it's ninety nine cents right now.
It's bad ass game.
It's really cool.
It's fun to play.
It looked bad ass,
you know?
And if you're really into video games
for the IPADS,
it's a,
it's an interesting time because they're
starting to make like really cool high
end games.
The video graphics,
the graphics processing power of those
things isn't really amazing.
That's how you could watch these dvds on
it.
Full high resolution movies.
I mean there.
It's the technology that they have today
is awesome and it allows you to have a
game like blade center.
So right now until
December 29th,
it's ninety nine cents.
Go check it out.
Fox.
Okay.
Alright.
Take a bath.
Go get.
Get your shit together.
All of you.
We were also brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t and a what on it is.
It is a sort of a.
We don't have a name for what kind of
company that says because what we're
trying to do is trying to sell you all
things.
Bad Ass.
Anything that's good for you.
Anything that's healthy,
anything that promotes cognitive
function or athletic performance or
anything that can enhance your fitness.
Anything that's good for your body.
That's what we're trying to do.
We're just trying to get you the best
health nutrition and supplements that
are available.
We're trying to find you the best shit
and sell it.
Anytime I find out about anything cool,
whether it's his Keith Weber Kettle Bell
DVD that we're selling now we just start
selling it like,
why wouldn't we fucking sell it if it's
bad ass sell it.
That's how we feel about these BLENDTEC
blenders and kettle bells and battle
ropes and everything.
Breastfed
is all that comp.
What?
Somebody told me too that you can put
coffee beans and a BLENDTEC blender and
I grind it up.
You know if you don't have a no,
if you don't have a coffee grinder and
so I put a whole bag of coffee in there.
What did it do?
It caught on fire.
It's dangerous and it took me like an
hour to get that shit out there.
It becomes.
It was psychology.
I started off as a smoke.
No,
it's like,
oh damn.
That shit's fucking crazy.
It's like,
must be able to the bean dust or
something and then it.
Then it just starts.
It seriously got so hot that I felt it
and I was like,
oh no,
that's.
There's a fire starting in there and I
turned it off.
Yeah.
Like that's kind of an interesting
thought.
Like you're not supposed to blend
everything.
No,
I don't think like maybe I.
ipads aren't a great idea.
They blend iphone.
So you've seen those ads blend BLENDTEC
ads.
I mean they turn an iphone into dust.
How can we can do that,
but it can't do coffee.
That's strange.
I don't know.
It smelled up the whole house.
Not In a good coffee.
My
friction thing.
Oh yeah.
The blades go so fast that the beans
smoke.
Yeah.
Right.
If you want to start a fire near a cave
man and he had a Blendtec blender,
that's what you would do.
It's awesome for celery though.
I'll tell you that if fox salary up
salary and Kale and cucumbers because it
has water in it.
Shit up.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's weird.
There's this.
Really what it is is like a ridiculously
powered blender.
I mean it's ridiculous and it has like
little cycles.
It goes on,
you know,
like when I make that bulletproof
coffee,
my kids run out of the room because
they're scared of the noise because
it's,
it's scary.
It's.
You should probably have like a big
shield in front of you.
Yeah.
For it.
Like,
like imagine having like your neighbors.
If you live in an apartment complex and
you have a Blendtec blender,
you're doing Kale all day long.
It probably fucking hate you.
Yeah.
If you want those 6:00
AM fitness Douche bag.
Yeah.
Show everybody how bad ass you are by
running at am.
Guess what?
Dummy you can run at noon to get your
sleep in.
It's not always good.
It's always good to get up at 6:00
AM anyway.
Don't blend coffee,
beans or coffee.
Do blend coffee beans.
And don't say you listened to this
podcast.
Your choice.
Either way I'm on it.
What else do we have that's new?
I think I've said everything.
Oh no,
that's a,
that's not this this week.
Um.
Oh,
the buffalo bars.
That's another thing that we've started
carrying on.
We started carrying these natural
buffalo jerky bars.
They're fucking bad ass.
I got right here.
Um,
but uh,
they're um,
they're made like this ancient Indian
way with cranberries and shit.
Oh.
And we also have killer bee honey.
Why?
Because it sounds gangster as fuck.
Okay.
Even if it's not even quite as good as
regular honey,
you still ganged it from some fucking
killer bees.
Okay.
On it.
Dot Com.
Use the code named Logan Rogan.
That's rjn.
Use that code name broken.
No,
just me.
Use the code name broken and save
yourself 10 percent off any supplements,
any of that delicious hemp force and the
of that super nutritious Alpha brand.
All of it.
Usually name Rogan.
Alright.
Brian,
at the music for this gets ugly
experience.
Are you okay bro?
There's a strange,
strange feeling in the room.
Ladies and gentlemen,
don't know what the fuck is going on,
but I do know that.
Matt,
how do I pronounce it?
Ven Ven grin.
Yes.
That's it.
It's a tricky one.
And it,
it's props to you for not changing it.
Well,
I thank you.
A lot of people would have bailed.
Has Been pronounced wrong many times.
Yeah.
Well,
it's funny,
but like parents from other,
uh,
like,
like really,
uh,
countries with very unusual last names
like Swartz,
Negra,
the amount of pressure,
they must have changed our name to
something that the American people can
pronounce a sloppy ass bitches I would
say.
So I the worst is virgin.
I've heard virgin many times.
Salto when,
when you were a virgin,
was that painful?
It felt bad.
Matt is a professional poker player and
you're a friend of our friend.
Aubrey's and a Alpha brain enthusiastic.
And I guess you,
uh,
apparently he said that you help like
fighters sometimes with their mental
game planning.
Yes.
I have two fighters right now,
Martin Kelman and calmly that I've
worked with.
So I basically just focused on getting
them present mentally before their
fights because poker.
Sorry,
go ahead.
No,
please go.
Because poker is basically like 95
percent mental.
So I've found ways to prepare myself
and you know,
I think it helps with mma because it's
pure competition and if you're not there
mentally,
you know,
it doesn't matter how good you are,
you can get caught really easy if you're
not paying attention.
Yeah.
That's a subtle aspect to a,
to fighting that.
I think a lot of people aren't aware of
the fact that a guy can look exactly the
same and be moving up,
but he could have lapses.
There's mental lapses that happened in
some guys.
Those mental lapses sort of defined
their careers because they have a lot of
talent,
but they,
for whatever reason,
they can never put it together.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean if you get caught with one
submission,
just one second off you could,
you could be out,
you know,
you could be tapping and it's the same
thing with poker that's wives saw the
both were kind of correlated and I
wanted to do something new and
different.
That hasn't really been done.
How did you get brought in on this?
On which the coaching.
You know,
one day I was,
I actually was watching Martin fight and
I saw,
um,
a lapse in his eyes where he was kind of
looking one way and then he was kind of
lackadaisical for a minute and it got
put away and I was like,
which was after Paul,
Tiago,
I think it was,
um,
yeah,
the one after policy I'll go.
He had a loss.
It was one,
it was his first loss out of his three
that he had.
He had three.
And then you had two wins.
Do you know which one that was?
I don't really remember.
I'll look it up.
Yeah,
well anyway,
yeah,
I saw him kind of like get out of,
out of the moment.
I saw like I can see it in people's eyes
usually because playing poker you can
kind of see that.
And uh,
so I contacted him on facebook and we
just,
we met about three months later and I
said,
hey,
I want to do this.
I've never done it,
you know,
would you like to be the first?
And he said,
sure.
So
That's interesting.
Now when you brought up that you saw
that to him,
did he resist it?
Did he,
did he agree with you?
Like what?
You know?
Because a lot of times this is a
strange,
it's a hard issue for fighters.
They're very emotionally attached to
their work and so if you'll say like,
hey man,
you know,
you got this,
you got to be careful with the way you
keep your chin,
like you're going to get hit.
Like you have to do something about
that.
And if you say that like they'll get
angry at you and it's almost like they
want to keep their chin up to show that
you are wrong.
That's just their ego.
It is a weird thing though with,
with fighters.
It is.
So when you,
a guy who is a professional poker
player,
a,
a non fighter goes,
you know,
as far as to say that you saw the actual
moment where a guy like Martin Kampmann
who's a fucking professional killer,
you know what I'm saying?
I mean mark kamins bad motherfuckers.
So for you to like bring that up and for
him to accept it,
first of all,
it shows that he's a smart dude.
Absolutely.
He's,
he's a very,
you know,
aware guy and that's why he's so good.
He's been very open
when he's able to step outside of
himself and learn things that you know,
that most people wouldn't consider
learning.
And I think that's really important for
growth,
you know,
as a fighter or you know,
mentally,
whatever you want to call it.
Well he got caught by Johnny Hendricks
in his last fight.
But you know what man at first of all,
that guy can catch anybody like that.
We didn't work together.
His last fight,
we worked for his three win streak.
We work
the other.
We actually kind of had a disagreement
on pricing.
So we didn't work together.
The last one,
dude,
that's a terrible thing to happen.
Yeah.
Wow.
You guys had a disagreement over money.
Yeah.
I shouldn't say that.
We shouldn't talk about what,
what it actually was.
It was just the disagreement.
Not a fair to Mr Kamin sure.
That sucks.
Any sexual tension?
No Martins is stuck.
What can I say in,
gives into the feeling?
I just let it go.
Got Cameron.
I'm a big fan of that dude.
I love that fight with,
um,
with um,
uh,
thiago Silva where he was losing the
fight and Tiago sheets for that takedown
and gets that nasty get locks it in.
That's one thing about camping.
He's a kid yet.
Why?
Yeah.
He's very,
very tough,
very tough.
And people to sleep on his technique.
His Jujitsu is nasty,
is you just,
it was just as good as his,
uh,
his striking is underrated.
Yeah.
And he was wrestling.
Takedown defense is excellent.
But like,
like,
um,
uh,
when he fought.
I'm the dude out of the military camp.
I'm blanking on his name real quick.
I'll find it in a second.
But,
um,
uh,
that dude has some serious,
serious knockout power and uh,
he took them down and submitted them.
This is Jeremy Foundries and this is
back in.
He's funny at one of your factories can
bang a big guy's scary power.
He's got serious,
serious power.
He never,
for whatever reason,
never completely put it together,
had some good wins,
but never completely couldn't put it
together.
But a cameraman caught him in the arm
triangle and put them asleep and that
was in camp.
Was fighting at one 85,
you know,
he's not even a big one.
70.
No he's not.
He doesn't cut much.
No,
I mean you can tell.
I mean those guys like the really big
guys that get down to one 70 and you're
standing next to him.
Like,
what the Fuck Demian Maia do Damien Maia
has gigantic.
That guy's really big.
Yes.
It doesn't even look like it's the same
weight class sometimes.
I'm just like,
Whoa,
what's going on here?
Yeah,
like thiago alves talk about.
Oh my God,
he is the brick shit house.
You know?
And the dude gets all the way down to
one 70 and you're like,
wow,
I don't know a couple of those att guys.
There's a guy named glazing,
glazing,
bow.
He's another one.
This guy,
I am not kidding you ladies and
gentleman,
he looks like he weighs 200 pounds and
he's fighting at 1:55.
He's so fucking big,
he,
I mean he might get as high as like one
80 come fight time,
you know,
and then when you're 80 and you're
swollen up with blood,
like when you,
you know,
you're pumped because you're in like a
brutal fight and you look at them
sometimes you go,
Oh fuck,
is that guy won 55?
How is that even possible?
It's mind boggling to me at least.
Yeah.
That's a weird aspect of the sport of
MMA.
Um,
did you uh,
mentally coach them on that as well?
Like the weight cutting?
No,
no,
I,
you know,
hardly cuts.
No.
See you were talking earlier about,
you know,
it's hard to tell a fighter,
that as a killer what to do.
But I try to separate the two completely
because I'm a big MMA fan.
I've watched like every UFC for probably
four years and uh,
I can't,
I like as much as I want to chime in
about technique or whatever.
I know that,
you know,
that's just not my right.
That's expert.
Right,
exactly.
So I try to keep it separate.
You're just concentrating on them having
a winning mindset.
Is that what it is?
I want them to get to beating the
winning everything
on their mind.
I want to get off their mind.
I want them to just deal with anything
that they might be thinking about,
whether it be a,
what's my next I want.
I want them to stay present.
I don't want them to think too much
about the past or the future.
I want them to just be right there for
that.
And that's the only thing that matters.
That's my goal.
And how do you,
how do you address their,
what they normally think about?
Like when,
when sometimes like big one.
I,
I've always seen with fighters one of
the worst,
his girlfriend problems when fighters
have girlfriend problems.
Man,
when shit goes bad like that can,
that can signify like a huge skid in
their career.
Sure.
Well,
you know,
um,
both of the fighters are happily
married,
so that's not an issue for me,
but how I would probably tackle it,
you know,
it's hard to get that stuff off your
head,
you know,
you can feel like that's taking over,
when you break up with someone,
it just feels like you can't get away
from that,
you know,
and uh,
most of the time it's just because
you've never faced that,
you've never really faced it down and
you kind of just push it aside and put
it in the back of your mind.
But the way that,
the way to really do it,
it's just address it,
you know,
go back to exactly what happened and
just deal with it,
you know,
as a man
and new pussy.
Yeah.
And it's also very important.
You cannot try to like,
you know what,
I'm just going to get my own shit
together.
Stop,
go get laid.
What are you crazy?
Okay.
I'm not saying go fall in love,
but go get your freak on best medicine
ever.
Yeah.
With someone who would also like to get
the freak out with you.
Okay.
Mutually beneficial,
that needs to be recognized that it is
mutually beneficial and that's the only
reason why it's any good.
We don't understand their point of view
and they don't understand are part of
you.
That's true in medicine.
Puts it.
You can die from if you take it with the
wrong things.
Yes.
You definitely die and or just ruin your
life and wish you were dead.
Yeah.
That's sometimes worse.
Sometimes worse.
Sometimes pussies worse than suicide.
How about that?
It's like the Red Dye and the Jelly
Bean.
Yeah.
We all know that one new to just can't
keep it together.
When it comes to girls,
you know the guy's a little chicks
dominate their life and yell at them and
tell them what to do and it's a.
it's a spooky thing when you see that
kind of shit happened.
Well it becomes really real for them.
Right?
I mean like I try to think of it as
like,
it's not that serious really in the
scheme of things.
It's not really that serious.
It is to them in that moment.
In that moment it is separation anxiety
and it's just as bad.
Of course,
uh,
for uh,
you know,
women that are involved with crazy
fucked up men too that are trying to
dominate your life probably even more
worse because it's scary physically.
Like the threat of physical violence is
much more prevalent.
It's especially if they try to tell you
what to do with your life and their life
is kind of in shambles.
Like a lot of people want to give
advice,
you know,
when they,
when they don't have their shit
together.
Yeah,
it's hilarious.
But this is related on twitter today.
Some dude sent me some,
a thing on twitter,
like some comment about how I,
you know,
I need to uh,
behave.
And so I was like,
you know,
that I need to like take a dose of my
own medicine or something like that.
One of them,
you know,
one of those sort of things.
So I'd go and look at his twitter
profile real quick.
And his last tweet was about how he was
depressed coming off of a coke binge.
And,
and I'm like,
do you think that like you should be
giving advice to someone about how they
should think like we're 30 seconds ago
you were talking about coming off some
off your first year.
Maybe you can say something that doesn't
seem like the type of person should be
given that advice.
I found out that liquid coke was,
you know how the liquid coke they're
using that they're also using it because
girls can put it in them and squirting
their pussies before sex and they're
buttholes and it numbs it down.
So you can just go to town on it.
If you put it in your Dick Hole,
it feels like you have the biggest dick
hole in the whole entire world.
Like the bones just gonna slide out like
a hot dog.
Man.
That sounds terrible.
Oh,
you just gave people an idea.
Could you imagine?
Could you imagine getting so fucked up
with regular sex?
Do you want to shoot coke in your Dick?
Like yeah,
sex.
Just not doing it for me anymore man.
But I found that like tubes up my ass.
The hardest part is getting that first
part,
like stretching your whole life to fit
the whole nose thing of the nose spray,
which is that what you would use on your
nose,
nasal spray,
a nasal spray,
and I guess a saline solution so it's
used for your eyes,
so your Dick cries all the time so it's
fine,
but then eventually their pussy and
asshole is going to start being numb and
then we're going to be in a horrible
pain.
They probably going to have infections
and shit.
That's all I'd be thinking about why
we're doing it,
but like she can't even feel this.
What Joey Dee dee is it just cleans it
right out.
Joe.
First of all,
Joey Diaz is not even a human.
So what are you saying?
The laws that apply to normal humans.
Just think about what Joe has done and
here he is,
fine.
Healthy,
still alive and made a baby recently.
Now stop and think about the average
human being.
If they go through Joey Diaz,
his life.
Have you had to go through Joey Diaz his
life and take all the drugs that he
took?
Find yourself in all the situations you
find.
Good luck reaching 50.
Good luck reaching where Joey is,
but you can't,
so he's not even human.
No.
You gave Joey Diaz is live to 100
people.
Ninety nine
be dead.
That's a fact.
We've.
JDS was a robot.
When it goes home,
his whole body opens up into smaller
little Jewish guy comes down and says,
hey,
how's it going?
I got to pay me working all the
mechanicals.
That's why its stomach so hard because
his stomach is like a knee.
He touched joey stomach.
It's not like A.
There's some dudes like give India.
You know you're hugging when they're
really big.
They just given to you,
joey,
as you run into him.
It's like thump.
It feels like you're sitting on a really
hard rock.
I'm saying if he's on one side of the
plan,
you should sit on the other balance of
bitch out.
That's what I'm.
That's
what I'm saying.
Okay.
Joe.
He does a solid dude.
He's.
He's not just a.
he's not fat.
He's a solid guy and his head is
gigantic.
Which a problem.
You try to lose some weight.
That's a weird thing with dudes like my
friend Justin giant dude and I looked at
the size of his head.
I'm like,
that is also a giant head.
Like if that was on a normal person's
body,
like,
like when you get really big,
if you get like,
you know,
certain dudes they get like incredibly
obese will everything grows and then
when they bring their body in,
when they lose the weight,
it looks very strange.
It's like what's going on?
Like why is his head's so big?
Like,
what's,
is it good?
I'm used to this giant Bonnie and it's
just unusual for me or why?
What is,
what's going on here?
That's a sad thing though.
When you see someone who's,
uh,
lost their marbles so bad,
the eat themselves into oblivion.
You know,
when you read about like people that get
stuck in trailers and they got to cut a
hole through the wall,
pull their couch out in,
bedded into the couch.
It's fucked to know that people can go
that far off the rails.
Do you ever watch Dr Oz?
I've watched it before.
What do you think about him?
He's not that bad.
Right.
He's pretty interesting.
He seems like he's pretty legit.
Nice guy.
It doesn't seem like he's a bad guy,
you know,
I,
as long as they're not like super
judgmental and like tough guy.
He liked doctor Phil is on occasion
that,
you know,
I don't,
I don't like that attitude.
Like if you,
if you really want to help people's,
you need to get your act together.
That's not how you help people.
Stupid.
No,
that's nonsense.
You're dealing be rating them on
television but he doesn't seem like that
kind of a doctor.
So yeah,
he's a medical doctor to actual real
doctor.
Right.
I was,
I was just watching Dr Oz.
I've never seen it before.
It got really baked and it was,
he has this thing like,
you know,
everyone,
three out of four people are super tired
and there it's because they don't have
enough of this one medicine or,
or,
or nutrient or whatever the fuck it is.
And uh,
they,
they brought these three women,
this woman was,
he's like,
I can fix all your shit using this one
thing that you have to take every day.
Multiple Times a day and they're like,
well,
it's because I have four kids,
I have to wake up every morning at six
and do this and this and this is like
vitamin,
it's magnesium and,
and,
and uh,
on,
it should get on top of magnesium
because he said the thing is,
is that they don't have it in daily
multivitamins because it be so big of a
pill because you have to take it all day
long so you have to get out of food and
there's like certain food,
like bananas,
spinach,
a Chenwa and all that stuff that has a
high amount of it and it.
But if you don't have any of that,
you're just running on empty and your
body has to like freak out and that's,
we get irritable.
That's when you're just like tired and
fatigue all the time.
And I don't know if there's a way to
have magnesium every day easy,
but it seems like that's,
that's a big thing.
Yeah.
I took it at night.
I take Zma.
That's the stuff that,
that Victor,
Conte gut also says is a natural
testosterone booster or one of the most
effective ones.
I'd take that over.
I take it every night too.
And I,
he sent me a case.
No,
actually I didn't take it last night,
so I'm lying.
I can't say every night and it's great
if you're flag.
Sometimes I forget and it's great if
you're sick and some of them have a
Tryptophan or what not.
Trip defendant some something else.
Treat.
Defend is a,
that it's possible that they could have
that in there.
You know,
everybody makes their own little,
a nutritional supplement sorta
concoctions.
But um,
yeah,
zinc is also a,
that's a,
it's like it's a healthy mineral,
you know,
it's like your body should have it
anyway and we should.
There's a lot of shit that we should
take man,
that we don't take.
Most people just like barely get the
amount of required daily vitamins in
their diet and most people are not
taking vitamin supplements and then most
people are not eating that much
vegetables either.
I'm like,
man,
you are rolling the fucking dice with
your body.
You know,
you got to give your body nutrients if
you don't give your body nutrients.
It just fucking misfires.
And w the why.
Intelligent people neglect.
That to me drives me nuts because you
can do both.
You've seen me eat,
I eat shit.
I'll eat shit.
I'll eat cheeseburgers,
I'll go off.
But I also supplement the fuck out of
everything.
I make sure I'm always taken vitamins
and for the most part when I'm not
eating a fucking pastrami sandwich,
I will eat really healthy.
So I'll allow myself these like French
fry binges and shit.
But for the most part I'm eating really
healthy.
But if you really stone watching Dr Oz,
you're like okay,
this woman says she eats healthiest.
Heck she has the greatest diet ever.
She's just tired all the time.
And the other girl was like,
no,
I have 15 kids.
I'm,
I eat normal.
Like I,
I probably have enough.
Magnesium is probably not magnesium and
not like a 25 year old crack addict,
you know?
And,
and,
and he just like blew it off.
Like all.
Alright,
see magnesium.
What's the secret?
And then he moves onto this next girl,
she's like,
I can't poop.
I tried everything.
I tried yogurts,
I try fruit and stuff like that.
And he goes,
well,
you need to try live culture,
yogurt and raspberries.
And she's just,
like I just said,
I've tried yogurt and fruits and stuff
like that.
And it was just like,
move on.
I'm Dr Oz to Dr Oz.
And it's just a bunch of little fails.
He has good advice,
but the shows is a bunch of little fails
over and over again.
I highly recommend watching Dr.
I was super stoked.
Oh Wow.
Nice.
I wonder if there's a collection of Dr
Oz's fails and if that sounds okay.
Not like half the time it's the people
even say anything.
You could just tell by their faces.
They're like,
I just told you fruit in.
I think I got something wrong.
There can be something really wrong with
you when there's some people they have
to do poop transplants.
So have you heard of this,
where you take my picture and put it in
your butt wherever?
Yes.
I'm not joking.
I wonder if it.
Whether they do it between family
members.
That's a really interesting question.
Um,
but,
but it's true.
It really is true.
They need fecal transplants.
What do they think of next?
I think fucking saves people's lives,
man.
Really?
Man.
Science as a mother Fucker,
isn't it?
It's just they're always coming up with
some incredible shit that just makes you
go.
How did this even happen?
Well,
I,
I always find interesting to look back
and be like,
Oh,
well,
20 years ago or whatever,
a long time ago,
lobotomies were considered,
you know,
normal,
right?
Like how it changes how science changes.
Like,
Oh,
our bad.
Yeah,
that's not good.
We can't really do that anymore.
I would like to think that we're way
past that.
I would like to.
We're way past the law bottomy stage.
I would like to think that they pretty
much know exactly what everything does
as far as like what the negative health
benefit or repercussions are.
But then you see pharmaceutical drugs
and you find out that's not really the
case.
I see like every week some new thing
gets fucking yanked off the shelves from
recall signs of maybe they did do a lot
of good though too.
I mean there's a lot of people that are
alive because of pharmaceutical drugs
because a lot of people that they have
illnesses and they literally keeps them
alive.
I uh,
I had back surgery a couple years ago
and the pain pills they have are
amazing.
Like I had shit no after,
uh,
after I healed up I got off on.
But like before that.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Actually I know,
I tried to get off them.
Here's what happened.
I,
I tried to quit cold Turkey and I got
physically ill,
like my whole body just felt like I
wanted to die and I was like,
oh.
I was like,
all right,
I better weaned myself off and stuff.
So I just did like two and then one.
And what specifically were you taking
hydrocodone?
I think it was hydrocodone.
Is that the same as Oxycontin or
oxycodone is what it's called and maybe
it sounds kind of someone.
I don't know.
I'm not a doctor.
Yeah,
those,
uh,
it's an opiate based hoping it will be a
base,
but that will mess your body.
Like I can understand why people get
addicted because like I said,
I tried to get off and it just,
my whole body was like wanting to die.
I felt like.
So it just,
uh,
you,
you get it,
it gets attached to your stuff
basically.
Yeah.
Kinda like a,
uh,
you know,
that Spiderman,
Velma was that the black van them,
right?
Yeah,
sort of like that.
Like it just Kinda Tanya isn't crazy
that they just trust that people are
going to have the willpower to get
through those.
I mean,
it is crazy.
It's crazy.
It's nuts that they're allowing people
to become junkies.
Like literally anything like that that
can get a normal look.
There's,
there's certain people that could get
addicted to almost anything.
They have a mental illness.
It's a mental issue,
but there's a physical addiction is a
completely different story.
You're not talking about some weird
thing like washing your hands or playing
poker.
You're talking about something crazy
where you've gotten your body physically
addicted.
This for its new system,
this is the system,
the system is heroin and terrorists runs
on.
It's like you have some business chick
who's a clip was got a clipboard in
their hand and she's like leading on a
tour through your body.
We started incorporating heroine three
years ago.
Without it,
we die,
you know,
so this is where the heroin comes in.
These are holes.
See this,
this is called gang green's.
What happened to you on 10 to your
holes?
But you get someone hooked on something
like that.
It's so hard for them to stop.
Yeah.
It's why it's the most evil thing in the
world to be selling.
Things like that.
Knowing that you don't have to,
you know,
knowing that this must be alternatives.
I understand there's some people that
are in intense pain,
especially people that are about to die,
you know?
And maybe it'd be good for that.
Sure.
But for the most part,
most people,
well,
most people don't need it.
Shouldn't give them the.
Most people don't eat it.
Yeah.
So how did you engineer your back?
Uh,
it was like a genetic thing basically,
like out of pineal cyst on my tailbone,
so I had to get it like a 12 inch
portion of my back taken out.
It sucks.
Oh my God.
It's all healed now.
But it was terrible for like 60.
You were a foot taller than you are now,
is that what you're saying?
I was actually eight feet and six
inches.
Three years.
He was like a foot shorter.
Yeah,
they wouldn't let me play in the NBA
anymore.
You,
um,
so this,
is this how you got involved with,
um,
like a,
like mind over body type shit in the
first place because you were like that
whole John Sarno type thing?
No,
what's up John Sarno was this guy.
Oh,
the,
the doctor that believes there's a mind
body connection with back injuries and
shit like that.
Have you ever heard?
Yes,
I have now.
I remember.
Um,
what do you believe?
I believe you do.
I believe it.
Yeah,
I think um,
I,
uh,
I feel like I didn't have much support
back then and I think that's what the
bank is support in your life.
You know what I mean?
So for me it's real.
I mean,
I don't know.
That's how I feel at least.
So you have this injury you haven't
repaired?
Yeah.
And how long did it take before you were
like 100 percent.
Okay.
That was like,
I'm five months of,
of basically nothingness.
I'm asking you all these questions
because I just discovered recently have
a bulging disc.
I have a bulging disc in my back.
It's not bad.
It's not really bad.
Like I can still do,
I can do kickboxing and no problem.
I do all these strength and conditioning
exercises.
No problem.
My problem only comes when I do Jujitsu
and I get my head yanked on that was
going to say that again when you're
defending from something it's because
it's in the middle of my back and it's
hustle found out to my posture is dog
shit most was already.
So I'm trying to sit up straight and
put,
you know,
it's like I sit like this all the time
and apparently that's bad.
I'm the exact same way and I feel like I
don't like doing this because it feels
like I'm just putting out my boobs saw
the boy looks at it.
Yeah.
Especially I'm trying to look less
Douchey,
not more Jewish.
This makes me look more Douchey,
like sitting straight up,
like I can be more chill like this,
you know what I'm saying?
But this is like way better for your
body.
Sit Straight.
But then someone said this is John Sarno
book and then I should read it so I
shouldn't really shouldn't comment until
I read it,
but.
But I'm not in pain like all the time.
It's a weird thing to try to describe to
people because it's like saying,
well it only hurts when I do two digits
or they'll just say,
don't do Jujitsu.
I know exactly what you're saying,
but it's don't do.
Jujitsu is not really that much of an
option for me.
It's been annoying that I haven't been
able to do it regularly for the past
five months while this thing has been
healing up.
So I'm trying all sorts of different
ways,
but I,
I know it's a real injury,
like that's the weird thing.
Like when someone says it's like,
you know,
senior mine man.
Well it may manifest the same.
Yeah,
I think it's like it may manifest itself
if you're thinking about it where you
have issues in that area.
But who knows.
I mean that's hard though because it
manifested itself defending a triangle
guy was trying to fucking tapped me and
I'm trying to get out and I'm using my
back.
That's what it manifested itself.
I don't,
I just,
I'm not being defensive and to start
starnell fans will jump in right now and
go,
come on.
Moon full could choose you.
Said you didn't.
I will read the book and I will read the
book with a 100 percent open mind.
But you can't tell me that that injury
happened because of my mind or that
there's pain because of my mind because
I'm not really like a Weirdo and uh,
I'm not buying that shit.
Alright.
I don't have this like self hating thing
going on.
I don't have any tension as far as my
life goes and I'm carrying in my back.
No,
I tried to get out of something and I
hurt my back.
Sure.
Like this is like tissue and it tears,
so that's where like scientists go
fucking bananas and a lot of medical
doctors that replaced disks.
They go bananas when they hear this shit
like,
listen bitch,
you got bone on bone.
You don't have a desk anymore.
You're gonna be in pain,
period.
No matter what this guy says in his
wacky book,
if you have like a real physical
injuries back,
injuries are tricky,
man.
They're the worst I think because it's
like,
well,
well he would be saying,
and I'm not saying he's wrong in saying
this,
but what he would be saying by saying
that somehow know that you control where
you're injured and control,
like where you feel pain because of your
emotional state.
What we're basically saying is that
you're.
You're creating your life and your own
imagination and your body is just one
physical manifestation of you creating
your own life,
which I'm not.
I'm not willing to argue with it may be
very well the case,
but you if you want to carry the logic
of thinking that your mind controls pain
and actual injuries aren't real or are
created by your own mind,
well you've got to carry that all the
way,
bitch.
You got to take that all away and say
the universe is something that you're
creating in your own mind because you're
talking about physical reality being
manifested by the imagination and your
intent.
Okay?
Well,
just because it's your body doesn't mean
it's any less crazy voodoo talk.
That's still crazy Voodoo talk and I'm
not saying it's wrong,
but I'm saying if you believe that you
really should take it to the utmost and
say,
well,
we're living in a fucking dream.
Okay?
Life is your imagination manifested in
some sort of a representation of a true
form,
but there is no true form behind it.
We're getting deep.
It was.
That's the only way you're going to
fucking tell me that your emotions and
your,
your mind is why you have a back pain.
Like maybe you got hit by a car bitch.
Okay?
Know that's all possible to like this
idea that there's this physical
manifestation is because of your intent
and because of your mind,
because of your emotions.
If that is even at possible,
then you've got to take that all the
way.
That means your physical intent.
It's probably controlling everything.
It's probably not just controlling your
body is probably controlling your
environment as well.
If it's controlling your environment,
how much of it is how much everything
outside of it is real?
That's a good question.
It's a great question.
I mean I put this on online and a lot of
people gave me a lot of really good
advice,
so I wanted to thank them.
Especially dudes on the underground gave
me a lot of mixed martial arts.
Star comes the underground forum.
They gave me a lot of great advice on
how to Rehab and Palati seems to come up
a lot.
Yoga seems to come up a lot and that
book seems to come up a lot as well,
so I'm going to check it out.
Travolta,
backroads,
Travolta back,
rubs and fucking uncomfortable because
you never know when it's Dick's coming
out.
Hey,
you know,
if she would travolta would say,
Hey,
let me rub you theirs,
which is what his move was.
Do you know that there was one of the
moves that he would do on the guys,
wasn't that efficient?
Auto Travolta,
a back rub lore.
Not that I'm hating the guy and I say,
listen man,
you knew what the fuck you were getting
into.
If you're a professional background guy
and you guys don't have like a website
or something,
we can go and tell about which guys want
to get jerked off.
Okay.
If you don't have that by now and you
and Travolta's come a new for 20 years,
that's on you.
Okay?
You guys need to either accept the job.
You know what he wants,
he wants you to jerk them off.
That's you're trying to diversify.
You saw pulp fiction,
jerk them off.
Just check them off.
I didn't talk about my backup.
I had the other day.
You shouldn't talk about it.
I sent and talk about that.
No,
no.
That's awesome.
The one that was in San Diego,
things can get closed down.
Yeah.
The one in San Diego,
right in the border.
Don't,
don't tell a story.
Stories,
a story.
We got to be careful about talking about
illegal shit as this patriot.
Hey,
it's,
it's made up.
I'm making it different.
We have to say that every story we tell
alleged now on,
allegedly I say allegedly,
it's kind of cool.
Shut the fuck up.
Okay.
Just stop it right now.
I didn't know that existed.
So you're um,
uh,
who you working with right now with
fighters you work on?
Just calmly and I talk.
I'm talking to Martin a little bit now.
And when you started working with
Martin,
he was the first guy.
First Guy.
Yeah.
I just said,
hey,
you know,
I've never done this before.
I kind of want to experiment on
somebody.
What made you like want to like reach
out to a fighter and devise a while?
I love them.
I'm a number one.
It's like the purest form of competition
there is I think right now.
So that's why I love it because I'm very
competitive.
I grew up playing games and video games
and poker is obviously a perfect choice
for my lifestyle now.
Um,
but uh,
I don't know,
I just felt like doing something
different,
man,
you know,
just,
just trying something new,
creating something out of nothing.
So.
And Martin Kemp was just like,
fuck it at me.
Like what did you say specifically
there?
Really liked knocked him on his ass
because like I said,
smart dude,
smart guy,
tough guy,
very successful fighter.
Like what did you say to him?
Okay.
Follow my solid champion inside of him
and I wanted to be part of bringing it
up.
Yeah,
I would think you were trying to fuck
me.
Wouldn't you say?
Wouldn't you say that?
Yeah,
let me come over and get some Chardonnay
back massages and uh,
yeah,
it doesn't sound.
You would just assume
some bad sex was going on,
you know,
maybe Martin Kampmann just thought of it
as a sparring session.
Like,
this dude is going to come on my house
trying to get some butts X.
I'm going to light them up.
And in the way,
all the way,
he actually got some great,
great advice.
It could be like an ABC after school
special.
He thought he was gonna.
Get some free sparring in.
I told him I wasn't going to talk about
that on the podcast about the butts.
That's all what we already established
that everything we say is fiction.
So don't worry about it.
Martin,
your secret's safe with us.
Ariel,
is that guy always a girl?
If it's got a big area.
He's a boy rather.
No,
the only big role is or girls.
Puerto Ricans have used a few.
Cute.
Have you ever seen a man with really big
areas?
Oh my God.
Are you kidding?
This big as your face is Ariel Leo's.
Could you?
Yeah.
You could wear them as a mask.
Rabobank.
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah,
he's a big boy.
Magic wearing a bike helmet with this
aerial is on the side.
What's the biggest Ariel's you've ever
seen a girl?
Oh,
there was.
This one was a sad story that somebody
sent me the other day.
Uh,
it's this girl that was at playboy
playboy model in the seventies or
eighties.
And she was like super famous,
very beautiful,
and she recently died in San Francisco,
like on the streets as a homeless person
and stuff.
And it just shows her like how she used
to look and imagine her life going there
in 20 years or whatever.
No,
it's fucked up somewhere in her life.
Some guy probably if it,
if not set it,
at least thought I hope that bitch ones
up old and homeless and living on the
street with no one to love her.
You know what I mean?
I hope she dies in a car accident,
you know?
Oh,
someone.
Someone wished that to Brian.
I was just saying.
Yeah,
this one's how rude.
So silly.
That's never should hope no one ever
dies ever in a car accident for the rest
of the time.
A great show.
You reptilian skin lady.
Um,
but whatever.
Yeah.
Putting that kind of intense.
Oh,
did you hear about Lindsay Lohan is like
really pissed off at the scary movie
five trailer they just had,
has charlie sheen in it.
And let me tell you something.
I don't give a fuck,
but Kat Williams Williams is in this
trailer and it makes me wonder if this
whole Katt Williams thing,
which some brilliant fucking marketing
thing because if you look at it,
it's like a miniature early when look at
it and Kat Williams is in it.
If you want to play it.
Look,
I'm a big Cat Williams fan and when I
see Kat Williams getting in trouble and
all this shit that,
you know why that drives me nuts because
I want to hear some new standup.
I think that guy's a brilliant comedian.
He's one of my favorites,
so when I see them it makes me sad like
I can't.
I don't take any joy in watching that
guy fall apart.
Eric,
check this out if he's falling apart,
but if it's all fake,
see if it's.
What do you think?
Because it's.
I don't think,
I don't think
you would ever like do that.
His fans.
If it was all fake.
Someone else.
Killer open front door.
There's no need for that
bitch.
Stop.
This movie could give you aids that you
might get aids just watching this
trailer.
I know this might be the worst movie
ever.
Tell me if you think this is really
Leonardo Dicaprio.
Of course it starts to.
It starts off,
so loony tunes and it starts off really
shitty.
Then it gets kind of like interesting
professional,
personal demon residue.
Damon's got to the bottom of this.
I was told you needed a dream extract.
This goes in your mouth.
The other one goes in your rectum.
Hang on.
I'm sorry.
That one goes in your mouth and the
other one goes in your record.
That lady told me there's always some
ballerina who won't give up the
spotlight.
I danced the swan when I was pregnant
with you.
This is not badly.
Don't inhale
judy footage that the old owner.
Stop this right now.
This is the craziest.
Okay.
Charlie Sheen is in bed with Lindsay
Lohan.
Lindsay Lohan's not mad that she's
getting portrayed as fucking Charlie
Sheen.
Let's.
Let's just say,
by the way,
is this like what she had to do to get
payback?
Not Lindsay.
Lindsay,
Lindsay Lohan.
This is Charlie Sheen.
Charlie Sheen just paid like Lindsey's
taxes.
I don't know if you've been following
that whole Charlie Sheen thing,
so maybe this is payback.
She has to do this film,
but they fucking own her because they
originally sent in this scene that
they're going to.
The joke is that you're working for this
stupid fucking movie or something.
I'm not working for the olive garden or
not working for this movie.
Uh,
but,
but then I guess,
uh,
they originally said was supposed to be
for Herbie.
Herbie supposed to be on their TV and
they changed it to report them for
sessions.
Scared.
There's nothing to be.
Sorry.
I gotta call you back.
Right.
Which I guess that was.
Oh,
oh my God,
that looks horrible.
Shame is the scary
was thinking that that clip is like
this,
these,
these constant jokes too.
Fucking up.
I've come back from worse than this.
Like this,
this constant playing off the fact that
he's like this consummate partier who
rebounds and it's starting to be like
parents.
It's scary.
You can't just keep it.
You can't just keep it
doing that.
Keep talking about being a fuck up and
bouncing back.
Like you've got to actually do something
now,
Dude.
Yeah.
That's the scariest pre that.
That is scary.
That's what I'm saying.
Carrie Williams isn't it?
And that.
What's scary is that
people were willing to make that movie.
Like they saw it and they glued it all
together and they're like,
well,
I'm fucking.
This is.
This is pretty funny.
Whoever's in that,
whoever made that movie is like a
genius.
It's just sitting there going,
Andy Dick,
that's pure madness.
That movie is pure madness that you will
leave that movie baffled.
Maybe.
Maybe you love it.
What the fuck do I know?
Don't take your opinions for me,
ladies and gentlemen,
but I hope that that Kat Williams did
gets his shit together or if he does
have his shit together,
I hope he explains himself.
I think he's fucking hilarious comedian,
man.
You go back and watch the pimp
chronicles.
It's really funny.
Shit,
man.
It's fun to watch.
He was good man.
He was really good.
I hope he's still is.
You know,
I hope he can bounce back.
I don't know what it is.
I wouldn't want to guess as to what is
happening to them,
what happened to them.
I don't even know about all these like
cancelled shows not showing up and
beating people up and shit sounds
normal.
I don't know fucking dudes.
Larry,
I'll tell you that.
I think you got to be a certain amount
of crazy to be able to pull off comedy,
you know,
especially pulled off like at Joey Diaz
levels or fucking cat Williams levels or
even Brian Cowen levels probably counts
fucking crazy.
You know?
It's fucking awesome.
And do you ever talk to Steven Wright
ever heard?
I was listening to his comedy the other
day.
He is a hilarious course.
I saw that guy live like way back in the
day when he first started making it
before I was even a comedian.
I paid to see him live and I was,
I was like 18 or 19 years old.
I went to see him in a concert.
It was amazing.
He said something like,
he was on this on an airplane the other
day and you forgot to take the seat belt
when he stood up,
and then he's like,
yeah,
I was dragging that F or did this
airplane around the lobby knocking
people over with my wings.
He had a great joke about working out of
a fire extinguisher factory.
Couldn't park anywhere near the place.
Just that kind of style.
Yeah.
He was the guy that,
um,
there was um,
a movie that was written about or that
was made about standing up called when
stand standup stood out and he was the
guy that really like changed the whole
face of the Boston scene because he got
discovered and when he got discovered,
they were putting them on television all
the time.
Then all of a sudden everybody else
wanted to get discovered to.
And it sort of changed it from everybody
was just going out and trying to kill,
just be the funniest people you could to
everybody wanting to try to get a TV.
So he likes sort of by his success,
unfortunately tanked the entire boss.
He was the first step in the entire
Boston comedy scene.
Slowly degenerating over time.
I don't get steven right in my face
though,
like know how you get Louis C,
k everywhere he goes.
Let me see.
Katie,
you know,
David Tomlinson,
but I don't see him at all.
One of the reasons is that
was not nearly as prolific as Louis.
One of the things that so amazing about
Louise,
not just that he's funny,
but he's so prolific,
like Louis puts out a whole new hour
every year and he's constantly writing
and because of that,
you're,
if you're a fan,
like I'm a fan of Steven,
right?
But was the last time I saw Steven
Wright,
special ones last time,
you know,
uh,
I downloaded one of his mp3s.
It's very,
very rare because he only has a certain
body of work and I'm through with that.
I've already eaten through it.
Whereas with a guy like Louis,
if you're a fan,
you're continually refreshed with new
stuff.
Like every year you're going to get a
whole new hour.
You're going to get all these interviews
in between.
So it's like you,
the relationship between the fan and the
comedian,
like it makes sense.
It doesn't make sense that I'm still
fans with Steven Wright are fans of
Stephen.
Right.
But I haven't heard any of this shit in
a long time.
But if he was like a dude like Louie,
that was like banging it out every year.
Like an hour every year.
Yeah.
He would hear about them everywhere.
It's not that he's not hilarious.
He's awesome.
Just doesn't work that much.
A Sitcom with Steven Wright and Katt
Williams and they're gay levers and it's
perfect because Kat Williams never
slapped steven.
Right.
Because he's a tall and stuff,
you know,
probably wouldn't slap them as much.
Steven Meisel,
dancehall,
he's pretty tall,
isn't he?
Williams was standing on the couch and
smack in your face,
right?
Yeah.
Coming.
You see on the video,
pop it at Walmart employee.
He'll smack you.
Usually what Kat said Walmart employee
was saying to him that way.
Slap him.
He called him the n word and that's why
I slapped him.
I don't believe that at all,
but I
might have.
You might have.
And if he didn't,
that's the right thing to say if you
want to get out of it,
I guess that too.
Anyway,
back to Matt.
A little bit random access,
but hey man,
I'm enjoying it.
That's how a real conversation is,
you know,
we'll conversations don't always go the
same way.
The,
you,
um,
when you,
when you started working with Martin
Kampmann,
did you come up with like something that
you wrote down on paper?
Like easily,
uh,
the ways to address it?
Did you develop like a curriculum?
Like how did you,
uh,
how'd you approach it?
It's hard to do that because it just
depends so much on every different
person.
You know what I mean?
Depends on how much time do you want.
We usually spend like,
I would say a half hour now.
What?
I mean advanced to work with them before
a fight.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
About two months.
In two months.
Yeah.
So d all through like heavy training.
You're there?
Yeah.
I mean I don't go to his gym that much.
I went to extreme for a couple of times,
just kinda hung out and just saw his
body language and stuff like that,
but mostly it's just on the phone or
I'll go over to his house and we'll have
of chat it out and see what's on his
mind and you know,
just try to get it off there.
And um,
you,
uh,
did you develop legere course for how
to,
how you handle this kind of
man?
I'm still so new to this.
I don't even know what I'm doing.
Sometimes you just have
some really good ideas about being able
to be in the moment.
Yeah,
the bottom line is just getting them
present.
That's the only thing that I'm concerned
about is just getting them to the point
where they're not thinking about their
acts or whatever's on their mind where
they can just be in that cage and all
that matters is what's in front of them
because if they go,
if they,
like I said,
we talked about before,
one second away from the moment they're
gone,
they could get knocked out,
you know?
So
what is like,
can you tell us like what's a,
what's a good way?
Like say if you've got something on your
mind that's fucking with you,
what's a good way to get that out of
your mind to smoke,
smoke weed and deal with it?
Smoke weed and deal with it.
No,
I mean,
do you know that's a joke.
But uh,
I'm not as funny as you.
I'm trying.
Okay.
You gave it a shot.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Um,
yeah,
I mean just,
just to deal with it.
Most people,
like I said,
they'll push it aside,
they'll pretend like it's not there.
Right.
But for some people it's not that easy
to just deal with things like I'll just,
I mean,
is there a tool that you could give
someone,
you know,
like that they could take away like,
oh,
let me look at it this way now.
Instead it was like maybe a loss loss in
the family,
the loss of a pad or something like
that.
You know,
for a lot of people that shit is like
absolutely devastating.
It's really hard for them to move on.
Right.
Do you what,
what do you do?
Like if you're dealing with a fighter
and he has an issue,
whatever it is,
girlfriend,
issue,
loss,
whatever it is,
how do you get them to like,
let that truck go.
You got to get them to go back to that
moment and live it again because they
haven't got,
they're not okay with it one way or
another.
They're just not okay with it,
so they have to go back and really go
through what was going on.
So in,
you know,
so you feel that a lot of times when
people keep things in their mind or
distractions,
it's unresolved issues.
It is absolutely.
Mostly from childhood actually.
Yeah.
Now how do you address that?
You say do,
like when you're,
when you're working with a fighter,
do you dress like specific areas of
their child that.
I mean,
how far do you go with that?
Well,
they,
it'll come up in conversation,
you know,
they'll one way or another they'll tell
me like what the issue is and then we'd
just go deal with it.
I mean,
it's,
it's hard though because a lot of people
don't want to do that.
They don't want to deal with.
They've been living with it for so long.
They're just like,
you know,
that's the way it is for them.
Yeah.
It's like,
it makes it difficult for them to,
uh,
to Sorta if they let it go like that.
If the game's over.
Yeah.
Phil let it go.
The game's over.
They don't get because they're mostly,
they're getting something out of it.
That's the reason why they keep doing
it.
Even as a traumatic experience or
something bad.
They're getting something out of it,
whether it be people feeling bad for
them or whatever it is for them.
There'll be getting something out of it
until they can let that go and,
and that game and move on.
It's just gonna.
It's like groundhog day over and over.
Yeah.
When you meet someone and they have an
issue like that and they keep repeating
and it's so fucking frustrated.
Yes.
It's so frustrating.
I went through it.
Um,
I've gone through it a couple times with
my friends with drugs,
you know,
and a,
or an o or alcohol,
you know,
when someone has just got that where
they will,
they'll get sober for a couple months
and then they fuck up and then,
you know,
it's like,
like literally,
like they're stuck in like a,
any like what are you doing?
Like,
why are you in this little track?
This is a terrible track,
you know,
the maze,
you can just go that way.
You can just have to.
Yeah,
this is your fucking crazy.
Put it down.
Pretend you're talking to yourself on
the table.
What would you tell yourself to do?
Would you tell yourself to keep
repeating these same stupid fucking
patterns?
He went to yourself for advice.
But that's a weird thing with people.
So a lot of people were good about
giving advice but their own life,
they can't follow that know.
Me Too sometimes.
Look,
I'm human.
It happens with me too,
you know?
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
You know?
It's,
it's hard.
It's hard to turn that same.
You know,
when you look at other people you can
look at,
I'm pretty objective.
You're not attached to their success or
failure.
You see them for what they are for the
most part or what you know,
what they represent to you,
but yourself.
That's hard to do that.
Most people don't want to deal with
their own issues.
You know,
lady.
That's why people give advice all the
time because they don't want to look
inward and really work on themselves and
a song that they would play on like zoom
or one of those little kid shows.
The most important person in the whole
wide world is you and you're hardly even
know you.
You remember that?
I don't,
but I don't remember it either that
barely remember it.
I remember that line.
Remember like,
what was I was six going,
what is this bitch talking about?
Don't even know me.
I know me well.
You don't know you.
They don't project your bullshit on me.
Six years old,
I fucking know me.
All right.
The most important person in the whole
life or help you in your even know you.
Very difficult for people to look at
themselves though.
That's uh,
that's one of the hardest things to do.
Straighten out your own issues.
The thing about fighting is that the
stakes are so insanely high that there's
even more pressure.
It's because it's not just a loss like
for a regular person,
like say if you like to play basketball,
if you have a one on one game with the
guy and you're pretty sure you could
beat them,
but you fuck up some clutch shots and
that is,
you know,
it doesn't feel good.
He's a clown.
You make it funny,
funnier.
He smoked you in basketball.
But that is so much better than losing a
fight.
The losing a fight.
The emotional.
Yeah.
The emotional aspect of it is so
devastating to a lot of those guys.
Oh Man.
Especially with Egos,
because look,
we all have egos one way or another
mostly.
But with fighting it's like you're
losing in front of that many people and
you've got to go back to the drawing
board.
You know,
you're not going to get a title shot now
for a couple of fights.
You Know Martin was right there,
you know?
Yeah.
Especially in a situation where you
don't like the guy and you guys have a
lot of emotions invested in the fight
and then the guy goes out and chaos.
That gets ugly.
Well,
you can't do that.
That's one of the things I teach.
You cannot think about that stuff and
not get emotionally invested.
If you get emotionally invested,
you're done.
Yeah.
That's so important.
With a lot of things.
It's important with even with art,
you know,
like you gotta like you gotta be able to
let the exist outside of,
of you know,
any,
any of your own bullshit,
you know,
to let it just,
you gotta you can't get wrapped up and
this motherfucker's eyeballing me,
bitch.
You really are.
You're going to be the one that shoots
first,
like all that nonsense can't exist in
order for you to perform optimally.
It can never grow if you order a few to
execute the technique and the best way
and to not have all this extra baggage
attached to your,
your performance.
Because when people don't understand is
that this is a very important thing your
mind,
and I know this specifically because
I've spent so much time in sensory
deprivation tanks,
this is a really big,
big,
big thing in my life,
is,
uh,
the,
the ability to separate and get a look
at what the fuck is really going on with
all of your thoughts and all of your
intentions when you're by yourself with
no distractions,
because if you have any distractions,
so it distraction is an unnecessary
element to a situation.
If there's a situation and there's all
this ego attached with you and this guy
fighting that did not need to be there,
well you've,
you've added,
you might still beat the guy,
but you've added a layer of difficulty
to this equation that didn't exist
before and you focus resources on it and
you only have a certain amount of
resources.
And guess who created that?
You didn't always.
The thing about the isolation tank is
that you,
you really,
truly understand when your body is
separated from any sensory input,
how much resources are going to that?
That will also affect consciousness
because if you have to deal your,
your mind is managing space as you're
moving around,
like bumping into objects and opening
doors and your,
your mind is managing all this as well
as communicating with people and you
don't feel like you're in any way taxed
or stressed,
but when you're in an environment where
there's none of that going on,
the sensory deprivation tank being at
the same temperatures,
your skin,
you're floating in there so there's
nothing come in into your skin and your
skin.
You feel like you're flying through the
universe.
You don't feel anything.
You don't see anything.
It's pitch black.
You know,
hearing your ears are underwater so
there's nothing coming in and everything
seems so clear.
It's like there's no distractions there
anymore.
There's just your thoughts and then you
look at it and you're like,
yeah,
what the fuck am I doing?
Like why don't I get out of this
relationship?
Why don't I stop drinking?
Why don't I quit smoking cigarettes?
Why do I keep gambling my paycheck away?
What the fuck?
Inside that environment,
those answers seem like so obvious.
Yeah.
Well,
what you just said is as perfect way to
put it.
There's so much going on in our lives.
We don't even take a moment to look
inward,
you know,
we're either driving somewhere or we're
eating and talking to somebody or
whatever we're doing and then we're
sleeping,
you know,
you never really have that time.
So being in the deprivation tank is
definitely huge.
I've tried it a couple times,
actually done in Venice at the float lab
up.
They just,
uh,
just that guy's nuts,
man.
The dude who runs a float lab crash.
Yeah.
And there's,
there's like,
there's a community of people all
throughout world that create these
sensory deprivation tanks and there's
some very good models.
There's A.
I had,
um,
a Samadhi that was my first one and uh,
I,
I enjoyed that thing very much.
I had great experiences in that tank.
It's very adequate,
but the level of sophistication and
technology that this crazy motherfucker
puts in to his shit crashes systems are
like 100 years in the future.
The amount of filtration that's in them,
the ozone and nobody.
No one else has anywhere near what he's
doing.
He put in this giant control panel.
I had to get it hardwired into the room
where the tank is.
The whole thing is fucking crazy.
It's huge.
It's eight feet high and six feet wide
and nine feet long.
Yeah,
I mean it's a gigantic fucking.
I mean he,
he's.
He takes everything to this crazy.
So now the newest version of the tanks,
they were.
The experience is still the same.
He just wants to make sure that the
water is as pure as it can be.
The distractions are minimal.
The,
there's no light that gets in at all,
but when you,
when you,
when you have this experience on a
regular basis,
you're really.
It makes it puts into perspective why
people do certain things where they just
keep doing them.
I'm a momentum and impulse,
like pull into Dunkin donuts or get some
fucking dead to horrible fatty foods and
stuff your face and you just fill a hole
for a second and then you're like,
fuck,
I'm going to go to the gym tonight.
You know?
And then you keep repeating this
pattern,
but note that you're repeating it with
actions.
That's what's really strange because
actions also require resources and when
you have an issue,
when you have something that's fucking
with your mind,
a lot of times you will eat up the
resources so that you don't have to deal
with it because the pressure of dealing
with it is scary to you.
So you create this sort of artificial
situation by actions.
That's why meditative time time,
whether it's just doing,
sitting down and concentrating on your
breathing and just trying to clear your
mind or actually doing something or even
hiking where like a lot of people think
hiking is like a meditative sort of a
breathing thing because you're,
as you're moving all your completely
concentrating on that and your life sort
of goes away and the stress of it all
sort of goes away
is living.
Yeah,
you know it.
Do you know how he's like a.
He rents them out for hour so he should
the mix like massage with flotation tank
imagines is laying there and having
another girl in a bathing suit just give
you like a real time massage while in
the flotation tank.
Can't that way?
The whole thing doesn't really work that
way.
And when you want to see her you
wouldn't want to.
You know what if she looks like Gollum
when you maybe the one of the things you
get to pick.
Yeah,
I don't think that plus the tank only 11
inches deep.
Like she can't really do that.
You would design it so like your,
your,
you can breathe in another planet where
gravity gravity's definitely make no.
Just one answer.
You can breathe underwater.
It's like it's a ramp like where it goes
up so your.
It wouldn't work to see if that's silly
because if it's a ramp
you would be sloshing around in there.
The woman.
That would ruin the whole idea of a
sensory deprivation.
Yeah.
Unless you're laying on like some like
fleshlight material all the way in it.
Like the whole thing's flashlight
inside.
Like why don't they make us feel good in
your Dick?
But it wouldn't feel so good on your
face.
You'd be like,
what the fuck is this rubbery thing on
my face?
Fleshlight blankets you.
It feels good in your deck because your
Dick is so crazy at Dick's willing to go
into assholes readily.
One of the girls like put it in my ass.
You know your Dixon idiot.
Your Dick is essentially
being shit.
Walls all over itself.
Your Dick is a fool.
There's a big difference between that
and what you're willing to do with your
face.
Like most people,
most respectful people and not rub a
shit wall,
a wall where all the shit passes by.
He wouldn't take a rub it all over your
skin,
but your Dick is like,
oh yeah,
love it baby.
For Christmas I got dolphin,
a vib dolphin encounter.
I get to swim with the dolphins and
hugged the dolphins and I know like I'm
planning it out already where I'm going
to put my head against a dolphin.
Just be like,
fuck me right now.
Fuck me and see if he can read my mind.
Like,
what?
Have you done that yet?
What are you talking about them?
We'd done it yet.
No,
I haven't done that.
Swim with the dolphins at Avi.
Tried like any,
like hacking to the doctor,
talking to the dolphins.
Do you have a broken brain?
Like you know what Mckenna like sat
there and fucking took acid with.
When would you try any mini experiments?
It was first of all,
as John Lilly Lilly today.
What's going on?
Did you smoke through?
I've been sick for three days.
I was sick,
you know,
for Christmas and the day before.
Thank you.
Still sick,
go back to the doctor,
tell them to focus on your brain.
Now this what you just said,
listen to what?
Like a rational person having a
conversation.
You're like,
you don't go to the dolphins.
You fuck the shit out of you right now.
People know.
What are you saying?
Like when you first hung out with a dog
or when you hang out with dogs,
you know,
you always sit there and like you read
my mind and I know every experiment with
your cats.
Never do anything.
I don't pretend to be doing anything.
Okay.
Let's,
let's be clear.
You pretending that your dog might be
able to see you and we'll talk to you.
Look at Dr doolittle movie.
I'm not,
I'm not.
I don't pretend I don't sit around and
go.
Can I read your mind?
No.
I don't know why,
because I read a lot of books on dogs
and humans and not once does it ever say
anywhere that they can read your fucking
mind.
So I assume that they can't read your
mind and then when I watched like
zookeeper that that's just bullshit.
All right.
Okay.
That's.
No,
I don't sit around and go,
fuck me,
Mr Dolphin.
No,
I don't,
I don't do that.
So you tell me if you had a dolphin in
an aquarium tank inside your bedroom and
everyday he looked at that.
Oh,
it asks you where it would want to live
and I wouldn't let it go.
Like if it was a crippled often it
couldn't move.
I just sat there and had to stare and
look at it and shoot it in the head and
we'll make the next life will come back
as a tuna to they sell retarded dolphins
for pets.
That'd be awesome.
Like you could keep it in an aquarium
because it doesn't want to move.
It just wants to sit there and drool.
But it'd be so cool to be alive and it
would still want to eat and like just
having a retarded dolphin in your
bedroom.
That'd be perfect if you were into that,
but I suspect you get bored because he'd
probably be really stupid like the
middle of
the night.
He'd be like a crying out for you.
He'd be like,
Oh my God.
You know how bad dolphin street sound at
3:00
in the morning when you're hung over,
but what if it says happy noises?
No,
it's a relaxing,
but you're just hoping for a different
type of Down's syndrome animal.
You're not hoping for like a normal
down's syndrome animals or an animal
with a disease for you.
It's like,
well,
it's a magical down central animal
that's happy all the time.
Well,
if we can clone them,
if they're 13 cloning now animal
cloning,
so maybe you can clone your dog.
It should be all right to close a
retarded dolphin that you keep an
aquarium that doesn't squeak.
You know what?
We're really lucky.
We're really lucky that people can't get
other animals pregnant.
Okay.
We're really lucky because if,
if that was the case,
there would be people.
Everything out there.
There would be people,
giraffes,
you would go,
how the fuck did this happen?
It would happen.
Would they get driver's license?
If you could fuck up an animal and get
it pregnant for sure.
There will be human animal hybrid all
over the world of everything,
of gorillas you would it to go.
How the fuck did this happen?
Some dude,
fuck does zebra roped it?
Held it down.
Shot.
Not only that when it was operating,
shot a load into it cam and not just
fucked it but came.
Okay.
That's a big deal.
I mean we were talking about before the
show,
like when you know you've been dating a
girl for a long time.
Like if you're bored with sex,
like if you're not sexually compatible,
you can get in those situations where
you,
you don't even really want to have sex
with them anymore.
We were talking about like when you're
pretending you're fucking somebody else,
like why your belly close your eyes.
Like oh yeah.
Thinking about some chick that used to
be like,
that's ridiculous.
You're getting actual real sex,
but you're pretending to get sex from a
different person because that's the only
way you're going gonna get off.
Well this guy,
fuck zebra bitch.
Okay.
Z.
He didn't have to pretend you have to.
You know it's a zebra.
There's shit all over its ass and that's
right next to your deck because zebras
don't wipe their ass ever.
They just dump out these gigantic jungle
shits and then you got to hold that
motherfucker down and bone it and get it
pregnant,
but they would exist.
There would be dudes in Africa that were
half zebra.
They would look just like the Navi and
then fucking avatar movie.
There would be giant Zebra people.
There's no doubt about it,
man.
That would be exactly the right height
too.
It'd be like a nine foot tall sort of
human zebra hybrid.
They would.
The whole planet would be half people
have fish people fucking fish for sure.
To to fuck fish.
I and a hundred percent.
I know I have no doubt about it.
There would be dogs would be ridiculous.
Okay.
Dogs would be like.
It would be like that.
The movie district nine,
when those aliens came down and you
know,
they had a fucking figure out what to do
with them.
That would be the human dog population
because it will be so many human dogs.
There would be like,
don't fuck your dogs.
They'd be like big billboards with a
deck and a dog and a big red line
through it.
Don't fuck your dogs because people
would fucked her dogs.
They would definitely fuck the dogs.
People have fucked parrots.
I guarantee you,
if a person can get a pair of pregnant,
there'll be people,
parent hybrids,
and it will be
flying around our cities all day
snatching purses and throwing shit at
people shitting on you.
Yeah,
for sure.
If people could make hybrids with
parents,
those motherfuckers would be like
prisoners flying in the sky,
dropping rocks on people's heads,
killing the Mashiah.
I guarantee you there'd be a person
pigeon.
You would look at it and go,
how the fuck did that even happen?
But there'll be a half person,
half pigeon,
like a foot and a half tall,
all fucking pissed off and fucked up.
Feet fucked up.
Pigeon feet and shit.
If people could get everything pregnant,
we would get everything pregnant.
There would be people,
trees.
They'd be people,
melons and pumpkins there.
There'll be people like Lord of the
rings just describing Lord of the rings.
But what of your loads got duplicated?
Everything.
If it wasn't just human being and be
like Mac book pro,
come over here and sit on daddy's lap.
Sperm just reproduced everything and
saw,
just shoot sperm on a water bottle.
It makes another waterfall right next to
it,
like one of those pods and that movie
invasion of the body snatchers is grown
under the bed.
Trying to become what it's,
you know,
I'd find a time machine.
I would suck my own dick and fuck my
mouth and get my own pregnant.
Now it would just spin in a circle,
like a cart wheel going down the street
and be two mirrors looking into each
other.
Forever.
Never end.
It'd be two mirrors facing each other to
oblivion of you.
Boeing yourself in a spinning circle
like you're in one of those cartoon
wheels going down the hill like one guy
holding another guy's foot or a dog
biting it's tail a dog.
Biting it's tail is the perfect analogy
is rolling down the hill.
There will be you sucking your own Dick
and fucking yourself in the ass.
And a giant circle,
a spiral spiral.
Fractal had a marine we could roll up.
What's his face goes on and billions and
billions of light years.
That's like a huge swirling galaxy.
Have a zillion trillion Brian sucking
their own dick and calling themselves in
the ass and a giant circle of impossible
reality.
Imagine.
Hey,
that's not any more impossible to
believe than a galaxy itself.
No,
there's no way a guy can be,
suck his own dick and fucking himself in
the ass flying around a star,
but shoes,
gigantic balls of gas and slash or water
and slash or rock that kind of makes
sense with molten centers shooting live
out of their tents.
Yeah.
Okay.
That makes.
Yeah,
that makes more sense than a dude flying
around sucking his own dick of boning
himself in the ass.
No,
that makes just as much sense.
It's just as ridiculous.
A whole universe filled with a spiral of
Brian's a trillion light years long.
All bone in them is less than half as
spectacular as a real supernova.
So I'm really impressed.
I'm not impressed by your performance.
I'm going to totally do what your,
uh,
your friend does with the stripper
pants.
I'm ready.
Shave like down,
like my swim trunks down to have a
really thin layer and then when it often
comes up to me,
I'm just going to see again,
you don't make sense.
What I said makes sense.
What you're saying is crazy.
No,
I go,
fuck a dolphin,
son.
Dude.
I'm just going to put my body right.
They're not going to let you.
They're
going to see what you're doing.
They're gonna arrest you.
Do you think the guy,
they're going to be a fucking website
dedicated just like they have sex
criminal websites.
They're going to have guys who were even
thinking about fucking dolphins.
It's sad enough.
These poor dolphins are kept in these
cages.
They wished they were out in the ocean
chasing fish,
having a good time with each other.
Know that we have to contain them in
some shitty little spot and not even let
them kill their own fish,
which is part of the big thrill of life
and some asshole thinks it's cute to try
to.
Fuck you.
Yeah,
Joe,
but I just found out their nipples are
inside.
They're assholes.
Did you know that's like the babies feed
by putting their nose up that dolphins
dick and it's like fucking shoots milk
its ass.
And so like imagine this.
Imagine having the best upgrade to a
butthole ever having nipples and sign
now you're.
No,
you're doing materials.
You can't do that.
I saw you do it on stage where our
dolphins nipples in the ass hole.
You're probably like,
what the fuck?
I'm just enjoying the ride,
man.
They're hidden side slits of the
mother's underbelly.
See you got to read Bible books.
There's no,
no.
How does the dolphin feed?
They had a baby dog.
These,
um,
they don't feed other butthole dude.
No they don't.
I know that.
I did the [inaudible] experience at
Atlantis last year and they don't even
want you to pet them around their blow
holes.
So you better be
careful.
Really?
Yeah.
They get upset.
Oh,
I'm not gonna touch the blowhole why?
Why,
why?
To take the bullet point when you have
the real thing.
No.
Brian has slits in the underbelly of the
mother and she releases these nipples.
She then the dolphins nurse.
That way you don't know what you're
talking about,
man.
That's you're talking crazy.
Somebody said that to me.
Must have been.
Yeah.
Well that person is probably Sam
Tripoli.
He probably sent you off the skids that.
That's so dumb.
You can.
All you gotta do is just Google that.
I saw you talking about that on stage.
I was like,
no,
they aren't.
I know they're not that.
I would have known
they actually brought me to like a
science page or something like I have it
on my twitter link.
Okay.
It's not real son.
Look,
there's a picture of a dolphin,
a female dolphin nursing.
Look,
look at that.
See?
I think it can nurse two different ways.
Can't do it through the asshole.
That's not healthy.
It's not a dolphin upgrade.
You just trying to say that joke.
How dare you.
Oh,
I wonder if this is true.
No,
it's not true.
Brian.
Don't wonder Jesus Christ.
Guys like you are walking here
located in his anus.
The cast sticks.
It's built into the whole of the baby
nurses from its mother through.
You're on the onion.com.
Okay.
Stop it.
No,
they don't.
They can't.
You would know that it was on.
What the fuck?
Facts dot commerce.
I think those things.
A lot of times people just make that
shit up.
I really don't think you can.
Oh Shit.
I just don't think that you would,
you.
First of all,
that wouldn't be natural.
It doesn't make any sense that you would
want to be feeding near fecal matter.
Why would nature ever set that up?
Yeah.
You're going to eat right near where
your mom shits.
Are you cool with that?
Otherwise you die,
right?
No,
no.
And everywhere it says they have nipples
in these slits hidden inside the small
underbelly.
Uh,
under the,
uh,
no question.
Yeah.
Every website that I'm looking at.
So it's the same thing.
They have these nipples that are hidden
in a slit in the underbelly,
fake dolphin nursing facts going on the
Internet.
Everyone's fucking.
They want to find out how people are.
They want to find out how dumb people
are and whether or not people will
google things.
It's probably an experiment and you
probably just led to this disinformation
campaign because you've been talking
about it onstage for several weeks now
without ever even once without ever
saying the exact opposite,
but I believe you because I'm also
seeing more on what you're saying.
Then
the websites that are saying that you
can,
they,
they are in their ass like uber facts.
Who's writing Uberflip?
Dolphin Reef Dot Com.
Anybody can contribute to these things
and sneak them in.
There's a,
there's a lot of these little silly
twitter pages and websites and where
they make things up on person.
I've read a bunch of them like,
oh my God,
what the fuck in your ass facts.
You know,
there's a lot of those that are not
really facts.
They're just trying to get retweets and
they'll say something crazy.
They get retweets and then they'll like
tweet out.
We're giving away a free ipad.
You know what I mean?
Like they get,
there's,
there's a,
there's a bunch of people that have
businesses that are set up just around
like getting people to their websites
and getting people to know.
So don't make shit up.
Sorry,
I didn't think people would lie about
dolphins.
Seriously.
You know,
I think people would lie about them,
but you did think that you would like to
sneak up behind one and asked one if you
could just touching,
rubbing it,
rubbing around the outside type.
Shit.
You know,
I just think it'd be feel good.
So let's have you touched a dolphin.
I have not even touched the it.
It's like raping a prisoner that you
can't understand.
This was like he's crying and you're
like,
you liked it.
Meanwhile in his language he's screaming
out,
please stop fucking me.
That's what it'd be like if you had sex
with adults.
Like if I touched a dolphin,
does it feel like your cheek?
It's like plastic.
It's like plastic,
so it doesn't look hard.
Plus it feels like a dildo.
Yeah.
No,
I really felt that Dildo.
Wetsuit.
Maybe your wetsuit.
You've never felt the deal.
Never ever lived.
I never lived.
I'll try it later.
I guess.
Clearly touched the tilt down.
Have you ever seen one over a chick's
house?
I'm actually only 12 years old.
Oh fuck.
He's got that crazy disease.
Yeah.
Dylan.
Those nobody's impressed with the way
they feel.
I mean,
you know,
I mean it gets kind of close to like
what a Dick would feel like,
but you'd know the difference if I put a
dick in your hand and then I put a Dildo
in your hand,
like which one is the real dick?
You know,
you feel electricity right through
riddick.
Totally feel it.
Have you ever sparked but your deck,
I wonder if it could cause your blendtec
blender to catch fire.
I just throw it in there and find out
all this show's gone off the in,
into the wounds to de de,
de,
de Doo.
I'm back to positive thinking,
man.
Today to say,
les miserables,
you gotta learn how to talk English so
the people understand you.
I don't even know what you said.
I'm sorry.
I'm eating one of these on it.
Buffalo bars don't talk at the same
time.
Fuck.
Did you see the Quentin Tarantino movie?
No.
No,
but uh,
was it good?
Jamie said,
it's fucking awesome.
Jamie says,
awesome.
It looks amazing.
I can't wait to see it.
Yeah,
it looks pretty bad.
Attention.
Quintin Tarantino is a bad motherfucker.
He makes the kind of movies that people
want to see,
like fun,
crazy movies where nutty shit goes down.
Did you see the hot end up seeing the
hobbit?
Yes,
I saw them.
Did you like it was at Dick's house.
What time did you fall asleep?
And I grew up in our,
in our,
in my wife nuts,
me.
She goes,
you're not asleep.
I go,
nope,
I was totally asleep.
You've got to get your points up.
I guess that's a new game that you get
your points and like how fast she can
fall asleep in the hobbit and 18
seconds.
I couldn't have to sleep about a half an
hour.
And you know,
the problem with all those movies is.
I hate saying this because I even make
fun of people say that.
First of all,
I read the books and I read them when I
was a little kid and they were like a
part of me growing up,
you know,
some watching it and I know that certain
shit has to happen.
So you already like it.
That takes away from a lot of the drama
of the movie because you know all these
things going to happen.
It's like,
okay,
well how are they going to happen as
opposed to,
you know,
a great film that's entirely original.
So this movie is an adaptation of the
novel that you've already read.
So there's that and then there's that.
There's so much to tell that it takes a
long ass time to tell it all and it's
just not as enjoyable when you're
watching it in the film forum.
Then if you're watching it in a movie.
So there's all this shit that happened
that it's just like,
yeah,
it looks really cool,
but it's just some shit happening.
Like the scene of they're fighting the
ogres and I'm like,
spoiler,
spoiler alert.
They fight Ogres,
but after awhile I'm like,
oh,
I get it.
They're going to be fine and let's just
watch them.
Cartoon initially have this fight that
has no drama attached to it at all and
it there was,
there was a lot of that,
but the special effects are fucking
stunning.
What they can do now is fucking
What frame rate did you see that?
Do you see the creepy one?
I thought,
yeah,
the high frame rate.
Three d was and people that were
complaining about that,
go,
fuck yourself.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Are you really complaining?
Like that fake version of the TV.
They were like,
this is gonna ruin films forever.
It gives the entire film with creepy.
To me,
it's a fantasy movie.
You fuck stick suspension of disbelief.
Isn't that the point?
Well,
not only that,
this is the most suspension of
disbelief.
He movie of all time.
It's a whole fucking you're following to
do with giant,
furry feet and a wizard.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Are you really saying it doesn't look
real?
You asshole.
It's not supposed to look real stupid.
Fuck face.
It's supposed to be fun and it's way
more fun when it's in that high frame
rate.
Three d verse.
It's bad ass,
man.
When I was at my friend's
house for Christmas,
uh,
her brother was playing call of duty in
three D and I put it on the glasses.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Those three d tvs,
those are nuts.
We had a three d laptop that alienware
gave us,
but we never played a game and it on it
play play portal to how was it sweet.
But I mean I also have three d TVs I've
been playing call of duty and three days
ago who gives a shit
man?
Um,
the,
the technology for those things has
gotten really,
really powerful.
I,
I saw a three d television recently at
one of those.
What are those?
Uh,
those high end fucking stores.
That's a audio visual store.
Yeah.
I forget what it was,
but we were on the road and we walked
into one of these retail stores and they
had this crazy fucking setup where it's
really thin glass and that was
essentially the entire TV.
It was,
it was really weird.
And you put these glasses on it.
What did we watch?
Monster's inc.
Is that what it was?
Yeah.
Monsters Inc and three d.
And it's just like,
it's such an overwhelming experience,
like there's so much more visual input
coming your way and like this added
dimension of it,
if they could just get it down like
that,
like the perfect way.
But like really bad at like avatar.
Avatar I think was way better because of
the three days.
Yeah.
Avatar just came out on three day.
By the way,
if you have a three d tv,
it just finally came out so everyone can
buy.
It used to be where you only could buy
it if he bought this $150.
See I feel like if you wear glasses in
your house,
you might be an asshole.
Oh,
did I love it man.
I got these new ones off amazon.
They're just generic for like 20 bucks.
They just charge it by usb.
So you always have them charged.
You just put on.
It's like putting on sunglasses.
But while you're laying in bed,
do you think one day we'll look
back in the day when we'll laugh about
the days when they used to have to wear
glasses to greedy fucks,
but it'll be like,
it's ancient data technology.
I mean essentially we're trying to
distort an image.
If you take your glasses off and you
watched the hobbit,
it's craziness.
It's like it's very rarely see what the
fuck's happening.
It's gross,
but then he put the glasses on.
So somehow or another they need this
distortion and the pastor.
Just a simple lens,
just a little simple lens that's really
close to your eyes in order to make it
happen.
I don't accept that.
I said nonsense,
so that I think until now,
not much these crazy fucks in the hadron
collider people,
they're doing some things,
but they're going to be able to figure
out three d,
three d is going to be.
I think eventually it's going to be.
Everyone's going to have instead of a
television,
you just gonna have like one of those
help me,
obi one.
You're my only hope.
One of those little things that she
stuck on,
r two,
d two and they're going to sit that
bitch down and step back and it's going
to make a show for you right in front
of.
Yeah,
and it's everyone's gonna be doing it
everywhere too.
You're going to be like in the parking
lot,
there's going to be like average people
are gonna throw advertisements in front
of you and your fucking thing out of
here.
You know,
I don't want to see this hologram thing.
Yeah.
You're going to be walking down the
street and you're going to watch,
like see through.
People have sword fights right in front
of you.
It can be.
Is that a real person to post?
Is that a hologram?
Hologram,
right.
It's going to be totallY pokemon shit.
Big fucking dude can add each other with
swords.
Right in the Middle of a fucking
intersection.
People driving right through them
putting me like ufc fights
on the,
on the road.
Just tryIng.
Yeah.
Right.
Where you people trying to walk through
head kicking each other,
like escort guys like in vegas where
they're like flipping the tickets now
they're just gonna be like interrupting
your fights with like the girls like
fucking giving blow jobs to other guys.
Yeah.
Trainees.
It's going to be all over the street.
You're going to watch tranny sex coming
out of the ground.
People going to outlaw that and then
they go,
this is.
I'm trying to walk on my kid to school.
Fucking looking at trainees banging each
other.
Right?
They're alive
with the censorship be there'll be like
a smoke that you throw on the ground
that like blocks the hologram or
something makes
me wonder like is there like the
internet is the only place that we've
ever had in our whole life where there's
no censorship.
The internet is just,
it's the wild west and it's free.
How much you like to spend on the
internet?
A lot.
Most people are on the internet for at
least an hour a day.
You know?
More.
So if you get a chance to be in front of
a computer at work and you don't have a
lot of shit to do,
a lot of people are online all the
fucking time.
How much different is that than real
life?
And imagine if real life had no
censorship at all,
either in real life,
you could buy all the drugs you want to
get a gun whenever you want it to get a
car,
wherever you.
Even when you do everything that you
could do online you could do in real
life with no,
no restrictions whatsoever.
How many districts,
what you wonder,
how much regulation do we actually need
and how much could just exist under
common sense.
I mean would,
could you allow someone to really
stockpile a fucking huge ammo dump and
you know,
have a,
a,
an armory of vehicles and tanks and shit
and like,
oh man,
you gotta stop doing that.
Or you know what?
You have to knock on their door and go,
what are you,
what are you doing over here?
Why do you have an,
a,
b,
one bomber?
The fuck's going on.
You got to stealth fighter plane in your
backyard,
bitch.
What are you planning on doing?
Man?
I live right down the street.
Yeah.
Nice to meet you.
Our kids go to school together I think.
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
You are you an army?
What's what's happening here?
Should you know?
Should there be any restrictions
whatsoever?
And if there weren't,
if you look at the way people have sort
of learned how to express themselves on
the internet.
I think the internet went through a real
bad time and now I think it's slowly
starting to like level out where people
are less and less tolerant of assholes.
Less and less tolerant of trolls.
Less and less.
That dude that got busted,
that was like on reddit,
you know about that story with a guy
who's doing a lot of creepy shit online
like because that's what got them off
like posts and fucked up pictures and
saying fucked up things about things and
these people found out who he was in
real life and they contacted his
employer and he got fired for operating
under a pseudonym online under a
completely different name than his own.
Not representing their company in any
way,
shape or form,
but because they established that it was
him,
they went after him and decided that his
actions and the way he was behaving
outside during his own free time,
they could fire him for that regardless
of how well he performed at work,
which is really weird,
but it also sends a message that sends a
message.
Well,
no,
we're more concerned with humanity than
we are with this idea that you have
these irrefutable rights.
Like yes,
you have irrefutable rights,
but if you're posting pictures of dead
kids online,
you might.
You might be a piece of shit and I might
not want you to have anything to do with
my life and just because we worked
together like I should be able to remove
that.
I should be able to stop that.
So in that sense I think,
I think it's sort of the anonymity is
slowly slipping away.
Yeah.
But for people that have never been
anonymous like me or brian,
I think it's,
it's,
you're better off that way.
You're better off everybody.
It would be better off for everybody if
we all figured out how to treat each
other a lot better online and be chill
and I think people because there was no
repercussions for a long time,
they just,
they had an experience that they
shouldn't have had.
They had the ability to affect someone
with nothing coming back your way is the
no,
no social repercussions and that's like
not normal for humans.
You can't do that in real life.
Right?
Why should you be able to do it online?
Well,
we're not a setup for it and I think
this is a total.
It's such a totally new experience that
I think human beings are culture and I
think all cultures in general went into
this completely ignorant to the
repercussions of it to completely
ignorant to how it was going to operate
and what the effects of human beings and
human instincts are going to be when
confronted with this completely non
human scenario.
The ability to communicate with people
who don't know who you are and not just
communicate like you yell something out
from that from a hill,
but write detailed shit about them.
You know,
and send some mean angry letter to them
and that you could do that and this
burst and had not have anything come
back to you.
And because of that,
because people have this unique ability
to reach people like that,
it presented this thing that hadn't been
resolved yet in,
in the human body and in the human
culture in like,
you know,
are our ways of resolving conflicts for
one on one.
I've been pretty clearly established.
You know,
the way people shouldn't,
shouldn't treat each other.
It's in the bible,
you know,
but you know,
love your brother and all that shit.
It's like,
it's all like the idea is,
look,
this is the best way to operate a world.
We have to figure out how to resolve
these conflicts.
When they're done,
they appear.
Well,
these conflicts had never appeared
before.
They literally didn't exist in our
generation.
And that's something that is escaping a
lot of people.
A lot of people are not.
They haven't really truly wrapped their
heads on the insanity that is the
internet and what it's done to human
culture.
But I think we've,
we've sort of wobbled it and I've got a
way better handle on it now and I think
that you see way less and less douchey
shit way westland,
less people that will just want to be
assholes.
It's less like,
I think if you could see like statistics
on internet trolling and douchebags on
twitter and stuff like that.
I think it's slowly tapered off.
I really do.
I don't think it's just for me,
I think it's always going to be a good
supply always.
You know,
just like there's always going to be
monkeys throw shit at other.
There's always.
But I think it's better.
I've even had people online on poker
like talk crap to me and say how they're
gonna mess me up in vegas and then I see
him at the table and they're like,
hey,
I'm so and so,
like they're trying to be all nice to me
and I'm just like,
wait a second,
you just,
you know,
you were talking to shit to me online
now you're trying to be my friend.
What's going on?
You confront them.
I don't,
but I should.
poker players are like,
um,
it's a weird way to make a living man
lot.
I've met a lot of poker players and
first of all they're all like really
intense dudes.
Everyone is like an intense and like,
like they're all,
they're all very focused,
you know,
like when you're having conversations
with them and there's no dumb
professional poker players because it
doesn't seem like he can really pull
that off.
Are there that I don't know aBout well,
dumb how colleges like a showing or
intelligence in general,
there's a big difference in my opinion,
between intelligence and education.
I've met a lot of people that are really
educated but stupid as fuck.
He just repeats shit and you're like,
wait a minute,
you're not getting the connection to.
Right.
That doesn't fucking work.
And they,
they,
there's no thinking on their own.
It's repeating shit.
But then there's a lot of people that
have like bArely a high school diploma
and they're sharp as fuck.
Well,
you know,
it's interesting you just said that
there was a kid online that didn't
graduate high school yet.
He made millions of dollars playing
poker.
Quinn tarantino didn't graduate high
school.
Yeah,
mostly we were just talking about the
django.
There you go.
Drop days.
Your god.
A lot of people will not.
I mean there's a lot of success people
that I know even just didn't finish.
I mean I
out of college with one semester to go,
oh,
I didn't finish college.
I did three years at umass boston and
maybe the only reason I did it was
because I didn't want people thinking I
was a loser.
I didn't even come close to grAduating.
I had a lot of shit that I like.
If I wanted to.
Like first of all it's taken like
elective courses.
I was taking whatever courses I wanted
to because it was on like a,
they have a thing,
like they had like different programs
for people that had jobs,
you know,
I forget what they call adult education
or secondary education wherever.
Yeah.
Because I took a year off and then I
started doing this and I was barely
paying attention.
That was barely,
you know,
I've learned way more through
documentaries than I did for those three
years of showing up at this building.
To wonder what the fuck I'm doing with
my life.
I was just talking about this the other
day.
I was like,
our college is necessary anymore.
I mean,
you could take your iphone and figure
out everything you need to figure out
about,
you know,
french or spanish or anything you want
to learn.
You can do it online.
What's
dope about college is the college gives
you an opportunity to be excited by new
and different people and new points of
view.
And I missed that.
I missed that.
That aspect of uh,
of college.
The social aspect.
Yeah.
I couldn't go Anywhere.
I was,
I was.
Well I could,
but when I had graduated high school,
so my competitive taekwondo dance,
so from 18 through 21,
it was like my most competitive days
when I was completely dedicated to it.
And the idea of me going somewhere else
to go to school was like,
there's no way I couldn't.
I had a really good instructor and a
really good team.
I was like,
I'm not going anywhere.
I'm not,
I'm not going to move somewhere and go
to school for what I mean,
I don't even know what the fuck I want
to do.
I had no aspirations whatsoever,
but I got so tired everybody telling me,
you know,
you're,
what are you doing?
Uh,
you know,
for awhile I would say I was training
for the olympics because I was trying to
make the us olympic taekwondo team.
And then,
uh,
I gave up on saying that,
but when I started kickboxing I started
getting beat up and I was like,
oh man,
I'm talking window.
Have some fucking holes in it,
man.
So then that stopped wanting to do that.
But the idea that,
um,
I was just trying to find some other
path in life and figure out what I
wanted to do,
like is terrifying to say to someone
because all I heard out of my own mouth
was,
well,
I'm a fucking loser and I'm always going
to be a loser.
I'm never going to figure it out.
I'm never going to be able to take care
of myself.
That's all I thought of when I said it.
But today,
shit man,
you could learn it least as much online
as you could in a school most likely
more because you're going to have way
more access to information than just the
few books this one guy subscribes to
you.
It's Basically just someone reading out
of a book to you is what it is,
but not only that,
you can do it all day,
every day,
wherever you are.
The crazy thing about online,
especially if you got a big phone,
one of those tablets,
phones or something like that.
Yeah,
you could fucking read like websites and
books.
You could do it all day long.
You can.
You have,
as long as you have a signal that can
come to you,
you have access to like pretty much
every question that's ever been asked
the if not the answer,
a slew of different competing answers
that you might not even get.
Especially if you go to like brigham
young university and get one opinion,
you're up with the mormon.
I'm saying you got to be careful.
That's got to be fucking the most
devastating thing for like religions.
The access to information.
The more people are finding out like,
well I remember when I was a catholic,
right?
And we had friends that were jewish
because um,
you know,
you live in New York.
When I was a little kid it was living in
New Jersey,
like the,
that area,
the east coast is filled with jewish
people,
but I didn't understand what the jew,
what a job.
I didn't even understand what it meant.
I would just hear someone say,
oh,
is he jewish?
Yeah,
he's mr feinstein and his wife of blah
blah blah blah.
I didn't know what that meant.
And then one day when I was in catholic
school,
somebody they were talking about like
different religions and judaism got
brought up and someone said the,
like the preset something about the,
uh,
the jewish religion.
I was like,
the jewish went to,
that's judaism and get another.
What is that?
It's,
we're judeo christian.
And I was like,
whoa,
what?
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
It's more than one version of the story,
like,
are you fucking shitting me?
Just that,
just them telling me about competing
versions of the story.
If I could have gotten online when I was
six and googled his religion bullshit,
just gone through every fucking piece of
information,
which by the way,
when you're six,
you could fucking read kinda,
you know,
you could probably actually do this and
you could figure out if you could ask
like,
dad,
what does collaborate mean?
You know,
you like there's a few of those you'd
have to throw out there,
but basically you could get a pretty
good idea of why you shouldn't pay
attention to these crazy fox because
every one of their story they swear by
and every one of the stories is
different than everybody else's fucking
store.
Someone's got to be wrong.
You know,
It's funny,
my friend stephanie,
she posted on her facebook the other
day,
a picture of two people with reading
bibles,
different beliefs.
And it said,
oh,
yours is fulfilled with bs too.
And uh,
she got someone from Saudi Arabia that
just went nuts on her for just defendant
is beliefs blindly?
No,
I used to do a whole
bit about how,
um,
the israelis and palestinians or the
arabs and the israelis are constantly at
war.
But they look so similar to each other,
you know,
and that was because they were sneaking
over and getting forbidden sex and they
would have an angry like angry opposing
religion,
sex.
Like you believe the crazy shit
crazy shit.
Did you see that episode of curb your
enthusiasm?
Where Larry David,
it takes back.
I'm a palestinian lady
from a chicken joint that he's not.
Well,
he's swimming.
He's single now.
Larry.
David?
Yeah.
The enthusiasm in the show.
In the show.
Yeah.
Divorced friends kind of friends are
trying to get back to you.
So now he gets new checks.
He's sitting there and stirred.
Can I swear on this?
Oh fuck you.
Are you serious?
She's saying she's saying she's saying
fuck me jus when she's,
when she's sitting on top of it.
So yeah.
Well that's sort of
old.
A bit like a who used to do that.
There's a black guy that used to do
about how like dating a white girl and
making her say fuck me with your big
nigger cock.
Yeah.
And then sam aaa says that every other
podcasts,
if sam do that too,
like every podcast,
what does he like to say that he likes
to say that word
being edgy.
Um,
yeah.
That,
that idea of the opposing getting it off
spit that's existed for a long time and
attention for fruits.
The black girl in a white neighborhood.
Oh yeah.
We're,
we're Silly bitches highway when It
comes to forbidden fruit.
Know we want,
we can have what do you do?
Anything to tell the fighters how to
concentrate on their diet when like
trying to,
like I said,
just let it in.
But as far as like not thinking negative
things because a lot of times like
that's all they think about.
It's like,
fuck,
I wish I could eat.
Fuck,
No,
I haven't actually dealt with that yet.
it's never come up.
I think that would be something like,
I don't know,
mike dolce is uh,
one of the best guys at,
uh,
getting guys to make weight.
And he's also like,
he's got a good mindset for like
coaching good mindset for like not
bullshitting with you.
And straighten up and he gets them to
the sled.
Compli,
we're eating healthy foods.
You're not killing yourself.
If your body's fine.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I'm fine.
You know he can fucking tick tock tick
tock.
But if you go on one of those spirals,
it's like any other spiral.
If you get it onto that.
Fuck,
I wish I could eat fire up spiral.
Fuck.
I wish I could do this.
I wish you could have a cigarette.
Fuck,
I wish I could have a cigarette.
And the moment you do that,
you're yourself down that path.
I seen people like this motherfucker.
He started smoking cigarettes again
because there's cat hurt its foot.
Stop.
And think about that.
He was looking for an excuse.
so much fucking cats for what I do,
man.
Fucking cats live.
This is crazy.
It wasn't because Of that,
that cat in the bathroom with a litter
box come back in a couple of days.
it was a ton of shit.
And that was the thIng that snapped the
big bowl of food.
A fresh litter box locker in the
kitchen.
Go to palm springs for the weekend.
Go somewhere
with that tap,
figure this shit out.
Let it do what it would do if went to
the emergency room out there in the
wild.
Oh,
it doesn't exist.
well I guess the cats,
you're not supposed to fix them.
Does your for no reason to middle night.
Like a foreign morning to start going.
Well what the fuck is that?
Shit.
They're calling some updates.
They call out.
You get bored.
They do it at night sometimes,
but my boy doesn't do that.
The boys really quiet.
He's a boy.
Doesn't really do that.
But the girl,
she's first of all,
my girl cuts.
Super flick and needy man.
And so she'd be like,
anytime I'm near you met.
She's like that like anytime you're
near.
And she only does that to me because my
wife,
my wife is allergic to cats so she can't
be like fucking with this cat.
So the cat gets most of the affection
from me.
So when I'm around.
So
bill the night,
you just hear here,
now
I got to open the door and go,
shut the fuck up.
Jesus.
You need a bitch as a father clock.
They don't even seem to understand as
well.
Wow.
And she's not horny.
She's 16 years old and she's fixed.
Okay.
So that's not the issue.
She's just been a ed bitch.
mostly what?
I'm fucking bored.
You don't have any mIce in this house.
It's funny watching babies crush ants.
They don't give a fuck about ants that
are yucky killed death.
My little two year old,
just crushing ants and then it goes like
this with a little bodies just flicks
her finger and they're out of her
consciousness.
Like she would never do that with a
mouse.
Like you couldn't stump a mouse and just
like kick his body into a corner
somewhere.
He'd be like,
oh look at this mess.
You got to clean up.
But there's a certain level of dead body
where we just tolerate it laying around
and that's ants.
He can't do it with a roach.
You got clean up.
Your big,
the disgusting.
Now fly.
You got to pick up.
Unless you're A dude,
if you're a dude,
you're watching tv and swat a fly like,
oh yeah,
I got them.
Fuck them.
Like on a table.
You might like might get up during the
commercial,
wipe it off,
you just flick it and forget it,
but like a roach that's big enough where
you got to care or when you get to like
mice and shit like that.
Anything that's got hair,
you can't just kill it.
Caterpillar clean it up.
What does that.
Why do we.
I mean we have obviously have a
detachment based on the fact that it's
out of sight,
out of mind thing.
Little tiny ant and you crush it,
but the other thing is it's like there's
so many of them.
It's hard to give a fuck about them.
It's true.
There's so many ants that the mass of
the weight of ants on earth is about the
same as the weight of humans.
Yeah.
Google that.
That's real.
I'm not making that up.
Sleep tonight.
Yeah,
of course.
It's an estimation because we.
I haven't been asked to be on any scale.
Have you?
I mean they're really counting this.
Is there a census where you have to
fucking show up somewhere and count or
did the girls get to mail in their own
way?
Because then we start adding pounds all
over the fucking place because no one's
honest,
right?
You don't have those boner pills from my
aunts.
They're made from an supposedly those
boner pills.
Like what are they called again?
Hot rod.
Six thousand or 5,000
hot rod.
5,000.
But supposedly there's ants in them
that,
you know,
the extract ants.
And I'm thinking,
wow.
So that means there's somebody and it's
like an ant farmer that has distract the
ants and instead,
look,
you buy this little bump.
You're making bone or your
stop.
First of all,
You got to.
Before we started talking about this
online google and find out if they
actually make this shit,
right?
Yeah,
it does.
I mean,
why would I,
why would I read a bottle and be like,
oh,
I guess it's a.
Why would you read that?
A dolphin as nipples inside.
It's because I can show you five
websites that say that.
No,
no,
no.
You can show me one website that has one
article and they all copied it and put
it on their website.
I looked.
It's the same exact story verbatim.
Okay,
well this is on the actual bottle,
so unless they just decided to like,
okay,
that's good.
It says it has aunts.
It's something an extract.
It's an ant extract type in x and that's
what they're calling it,
man.
It's fucking cialis,
you know,
that um,
that brazilian wandering spiders,
that's what they're trying to figure out
what that thing,
why it causes erections and they're
going to try to turn that into like the
next supervisor aggro.
You've heard of That shit.
The brazilian wondering spider.
It kills you and gives you this
unbelievable boner before you die.
Most people die of it,
but apparently if you live your dick's
done,
it's just like,
it's like taking an engine and just red
lining.
Okay.
just,
you know,
it's,
it's hitting the fucking the bottom of
the tac officer and then it just
explodes.
The engine blows up.
So most people,
they,
they don't live from it,
but if you do live your dick's broken.
So they're trying to take that as smart
people would turn that into a boner
pills.
I don't know man.
Here's the extract.
This one is just another one super aunt
and it's a,
it's a,
you can buy it for $34 and it's just
extracted aunts and they're wildly used.
An agent promotes strength,
sexual vego law,
vigor,
powerpoint,
anti aging thing.
So.
So we have all these ants.
There's so much fucking that a fucking
all have boners the same error
knucklehead.
I don't think you're talking about the
same ants.
I bet.
I bet that's a very specific type of
answer.
Does the fda have to say,
but when 50 percent ground raw and
extra,
does it say that ground raw aunts and
aunt extract?
Yep.
What that means.
They've taken a bunch of ants and
extracted it.
So each book,
that's what I'm sending each pill you
take.
IT's like $500 million ants.
Probably boners all adds up.
And it analogy is that
they have celery and celery juice
altogether in the same bowl,
right?
The aunt and the aunt extract.
So there's crush up the.
Yeah.
So the aunt is like the hard part and
then the extract is like the gooey stuff
that keeps it all together.
Yeah.
Meanwhile,
probably does nothing.
I'm going to create a salamander pill
tomorrow that makes yoU live 10 yearS
longer.
People will Buy it.
I might give you one of theSe hot duncan
swears by it.
Now I wonder what
like who writes these supplement
critiques?
and it's like all talking about how hard
your cockiness.
Oh,
I've heard of this stuff before though.
It's called um,
uri coma long full leah and it's
supposed to be a natural testosterone
booster also.
This stuff,
um,
I think this stuff has a lot of shit in
it that's probably would give you a
boner,
whether it's the aunt,
maybe that's.
Well,
that's one of the things.
It's just one of the ingredients in
this,
but that long fully shit
that is supposed to be a testosterone
booster.
There's a few of those is something
called tongue got ali.
That's supposed to be a natural and then
it's tribulus,
which everybody knows,
which apparently varies pretty widely in
strength and efficacy.
I think it's sorta like garlic or some
things like you'll,
you'll get garlic,
it's not that strong and sometimes
you'll get it.
You're like,
holy shit,
this is powerful garlic,
or like the way a tomato tastes like a
beef steak.
Tomatoes from someone's backyard versus
one of those pale tomatoes.
I think you'd get that same sort of shit
with a lot of these herbal supplements.
I bet if you could get that stuff like
from the plant instead of like some
ground up powdered bullshit.
I bet if you get like tribulus,
I think tribulus or route,
right?
Was it a route?
I'm not sure.
I bet if you get that shit right from
the tree,
make declicker.
Damn.
I found that you shouldn't take any of
these pills.
If you do ecstasy at the same time,
you can fuck your shit up really bad.
Break your heart,
your heart,
your heart.
Maybe you are a bitch to be fun,
but that seems like the best mix,
but yeah,
that's what eddie bravo calls.
Phone or flip flops to see.
Oh my agro.
Crazy.
What?
You don't have to take these pills.
No,
no,
but what I'm saying,
you shouldn't take viagra or any of this
stuff because if it has any kind of the
biafra or you're not supposed to take
that with ecstasy,
there's some real dangers there.
Yeah,
it fucks your heart up.
Bullshit.
Google it.
Let's don't take viagra with agora
ecstasy.
I learned it on air or air,
whatever that arrow in the.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Okay.
Era,
would I?
Yeah,
I still did it,
but whatever.
While you were living on the edge and
you're,
you're a wild man.
Well,
let's say don't take viagra with
ecstasy.
Sex to see.
Don't mix,
but I know so many people that say it's
awesome.
Oh yeah,
it does.
Because they don't know.
You shouldn't be doing it well and you
shouldn't be drinking.
Yeah.
Use that stuff.
Kills you.
You smoke it.
When I'm on,
when I'm on ecstasy,
I usually don't drink that much.
I usually just drink orange juice and
water and gatorade and fucking tons of
water and appeal it,
and
there's several dangers and combining
viagara and ecstasy.
First of all,
soc is a powerful mind altering drug
that impairs judgment.
When I talked like that,
it means I'm reading something,
combining it with viagra.
It encourages people to engage in unsafe
and risky sexual behavior,
aka brian's whole life.
Okay,
so you're saying that it's dangerous
because of that,
public health officials feel this combo
will increase the spread of aids and
slash or other sexually transmitted
diseases.
First of all,
if you have a real medical issue,
here's what happens.
First of all,
you don't say that first,
so I don't believe them because that
saying that first means that the most
important thing is to stop,
but sex,
that's what you're trying to do.
You're trying to stop aids.
You try to say that people are going to
get sexually crazy and sexually risky.
Okay?
That is not an argument.
You can't tell me what I'm going to do.
You can't tell me,
you know,
I can handle Being drunk.
I don't drive when I'm drunk,
I don't get fucked up and go buttfuck.
Okay?
What you're telling me that ecstasy is
such a touching drug that when you have
a raging boner on top of it,
it's pretty dangerous.
I don't think it's dangerous.
I don't think it's dangerous at all.
I think it's dangerous for some people.
Just like cars are dangerous for some
people.
If you give them a cell phone,
they text because some people have
shitty fucking self control,
but I don't think that this.
There's no,
there's no like argument medically in
that.
I mean there might be this thing called
[inaudible] and [inaudible] is like the
boners that won't go down.
Oh,
that's just from taking ecstasy or are
viagara rather that you can get that in
a viagara situation.
Like the fact that you're on ecstasy,
that it doesn't.
It makes it worse because now every time
you take guys like better.
Yeah,
you're dick has a heartbeat and then you
need to have somebody swallow that.
So few people have that problem with
those boner pills where they actually
have to go to a doctor because if you
have that,
that that's like an erection that you
have to go to a doctor for,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
no,
no.
It even says on the commercial owners
may last up to three days
that disease though that priapism,
the erection,
which is the technical term that can
kill your dick.
Just like the brazilian wandering spider
can kill your dick.
It's the same thing.
The exact same thing.
In fact,
don't go into the jungle.
Well,
if you can.
oh deon viagra.
Like say it is a check and you bang.
You're dying to have sex with her and
you think tonight is the night,
but you're so scared that you're afraid
that you're never gonna be able to get
it up because you just got to be in a
panic.
You know?
You know what?
I'm going to take six viagara just in
case is so hot and then your crazy ass,
which by the way exists.
I'm sure some dudes.
Sure.
and just decide that they want a dick
that's purple.
Just an angry purple bursting cock.
Like a ballpark frank,
one of those ballpark
franks that you like to spend.
Not like an amateur would do it.
And like burn the outside.
Know a slow cooker where that
motherfucker's greasy and sweating and
just getting gigantic die.
That's what your dick looks like and you
start to slowly see little splits in the
scenes.
We have thin red lines around your cock
and various places because the skin is
fucking bursting like a stretch mark and
a fat lady stomach after she has three
kids inside of it and they pop out
triplets and then her skin has to go
back to normal.
That's what your dick looks like.
that kind of stretched out crazy scar
tissue where your dick,
it's just barely holding on like a
fucking balloon that's being pushed to
the limit is just got up and went to
take root.
That's how thrilling my story was.
He's on ecstasy all blowing up.
Dick is too much.
He's going to go beat off.
Guaranteed right now.
Imagine you on viagra in you are.
You were fucking peaking on ecstasy and
you have this crazy rock hard boner and
you're in a waterbed with this guy.
It that those two medications might
cause you to like just figuring it out.
Don't forget that's the dude rather.
Yeah,
that's a strange look.
This guy had brian pulled up,
has long blonde,
beautiful hair,
and he also has a dark,
dark beard and somebody put that online,
give the dude props,
who is a put that online,
rhubarb rhubarb with the wolverine
avatar,
so you know he's got some taste powerful
x men fan and this guy has a some sort
of a g string type thing up his butt
crack and he's very well built and it
looks very handsome.
Perhaps middle eastern art or spanish,
maybe a spaniard,
but like a thick weightlifting.
Dave navarro,
I think it was a nice,
thick,
solid and tight as the underground would
say.
Yeah,
he's a.
That's a big boy.
That guy's got some horsepower to his.
So you're an ecstasy.
But viagra in a waterbed at a fucking w.
It's looks like we're gonna fight to the
death.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what I think they're trying to
say with this.
To try and not do it or fighting to the
death.
That's what I think is going to happen.
If you insist on pursuing this line
of action,
sir,
we will have to fight to the death and
the only other thing is the ecstasy
causes high blood pressure and
dehydration and that viagra only worsens
those effects,
but all that means to me is that you
have to drink water.
Like don't be stupid.
Yeah,
but sometimes when you're on ecstasy,
it's hard to even drink anything that
you feel like you're going to puke it
back up.
You know
what I didn't hear?
Hear?
I didn't hear strokes.
I didn't hear cancer.
I didn't hear any of the shit that it
would keep me from doing ecstasy and and
viagra at the same time.
I heard nothing.
I heard,
if this kills you,
you're kind of a pussy.
That's what I heard.
That's what I'm getting out of this.
If you die from ecstasy and viagara
together,
you kind of a not saying you should take
viagra and excess together.
In fact,
I'm saying you definitely shouldn't take
viagra and extra city.
It doesn't say nothing before the heart.
I'm saying you shouldn't for spiritual
reasons.
I think you know when you're involved in
that ecstasy feely,
touchy thing,
it should be nonsexual.
It should be that you can't get it up.
Just enjoy it as a human being.
Everything doesn't have to be about
sticking your dirty loads places,
brian.
Okay.
It doesn't have to be inside of us to be
all about you shooting loads all over
the place.
How will you let it go?
Pow and just be in the moment.
Hold hands with somebody.
Okay.
I masturbated and it used a paper towel
to clean up and it's through it on my
coffee table and then my friend came
over and we were watching a show and she
goes like,
she sneezed and she goes,
can I,
can I use this paper towel?
I'm like,
sure,
I forgot that was the load paper towel.
She's like,
oh,
what song?
Over a nice.
Well that's a nice way to sort of get
someone to touch your comment if you're
really into that.
Yeah,
and a great.
None of my dna is on her hand.
Yeah.
If you want it to come bomb somebody
speaking a combined,
and I got to thank chris
calver.
He's the guy that made this a buddha
statue.
Oh,
can you check this shit out?
There it is.
That's cool as fuck man.
That's,
that's your tattoo.
It's exactly like pretty close.
He just made in a physical form with the
third eye.
You can see it like that is like this.
And by the way,
this position that this thing is.
I didn't ask him to do this,
but what's hilarious is that this is
exactly the reason I got this tattoo is
because I had this crazy dmt trip that
really like made me reassess.
RealIty made me reassess my life and one
of the most humbling aspects of the
trip,
there was an infinite series of these
golden buddhas that was flying in front
of me and trying to explain like
positive energy in life to me.
And um,
I turned it into a tattoo and it
literally looked like that in the dmt
trip.
Like literally looked just like this
thing,
except it was made out of some strange
kind of light and there was no borders
to it,
if that makes any sense.
It does.
Shouldn't do.
Dmt has this very intense,
like almost like a two d sort of a thing
that happens sometimes where everything
sort of seems connected on one plane,
but then you realize that it's just this
crazy sort of fractal thing going on.
And when that was happening in that
trip,
this is what I saw.
I saw these things just like everywhere.
Would it mean to you man,
I was high as fuck kind of question.
Is that I don't know.
can't,
can never.
Who knows when you're out on
psychedelics,
there's so mucH different shit that's
going on.
Like for anybody to say,
I know that this happened.
I know that that happened and I have
said those things you can't eat right.
You know,
you don't know what the fuck happened
were interpretation and you're on a
fucking crazy drug man.
There's a lot going on there.
You know,
I wouldn't really bank on any one
possible answer to any of your shit.
True.
Do you,
um,
do you,
you,
you play a lot of professional poker,
you take different things like before
you deployed,
do you smoke when you do hormone?
Dependent upon the area of I'm sure of
course,
yeah.
Because it can be tricky getting some
weed and some spots.
Right?
Uh,
I would say,
I mean alpha brain the last year I've
been taking and I found it to be
beneficial.
Definitely it makes me more clear about,
you know what I mean?
Like when I take it I just feel like my
thoughts are just clear.
They're clear.
Well if it,
it feels to me that you,
you're getting what your brain needs in
order to function best to seems like
that nutrition wise,
how many do you take?
Usually just to do you take it right
before you do an event?
Like how do you do it?
Like when I play online,
like on sundays is the biggest day for
poker,
so I'll take it like when I wake up,
like when I'm making my shake or
whatever.
I take four before every ufc for four.
Yup.
It says on here you should only take a
maximum for.
Oh wait,
no.
Says do not seek four capsules in 24
hours.
Okay.
Let's say I violated that too.
Should I say for what?
You probably don't listen to me,
but I do.
Yeah.
If I'm doing it like a ufc,
first of all you have fcs.
It's a,
there's a lot that's going on like when
you're watching a fight and uh,
especially when it comes to describing
ground positions,
it's really hard to coordinate your
thoughts.
Like,
okay,
he's got his right foot in this
position.
Now what he's got to do to finish this
off because he's got to turn his.
And I'm like,
god,
there's got to get his left foot
underneath his right knee.
And then I got to get this all done.
I have to get it all out in a way that
people are going to be able to
understand.
While the fight is actually happening,
so I gotta kind of like manage.
I have,
first of all I have to see what he's
doing so I have to know what direction
he can do and what the counter could
possibly be and then when I see a guy
going after and I wanted to get the
audience excited,
I want to say this is where he's in
trouble.
Like you see this,
this is pulling down on his neck and
he's,
he's in a bad situation here and if he
could get his leg over here,
then it's over,
you know,
and the alpha brain and any,
any nootropics.
I took that neuro one ship before I took
out.
I noticed a difference.
I noticed that I could get sentences
out,
clear my thoughts,
my thoughts,
my thoughts for it seemed like they
formulate it easier and it just makes
sense.
I mean there's isolated a bunch of
different shit that improves your memory
statistically proven.
Like you can see people taking it and
then people have done double blind tests
on different nootropics when it comes to
memory enhancement.
And there's like prasad tam and a bunch
of different ones that are really
interesting and it as this caffeine,
you know,
caffeine has a performance enhancing
quality to it as well.
Absolutely.
Because you're more jacked up.
There's some shit going.
I mean that's why you can only take in
certain.
I think of the olympics and I think even
in the Nevada state athletic commission,
they have a limit to how much caffeine
of fighter can have in their system.
I didn't know that she also had actually
a set of hip to that because he does it
in a pill form to make sure that he
never takes more than than you're
supposed to because you could get like
starbucks,
like this one,
like a venti.
If you have a starbucks,
venti and you compare that to like
coffee that you're going to get at
jerry's deli.
This is a big difference.
Yeah.
You mean?
Depends who makes it to.
I mean it might be just different,
you know,
but more or less in there.
Yeah.
The starbucks ones haven't seen amounts
of caffeine.
So you might be possible to actually
like piss hot for caffeine.
If you drank like a bunch of a it,
I wonder how many you would have to
drink.
Like how many mentees?
I bet you could only drink a couple
before you die.
No,
there's dudes could drink that shit all
day following day.
Fully got to a point where he was
drinking so much coffee a day that he
had a drink it black because he was
drinking several quarts of half and half
a day.
What saying,
dude,
I'm not bullshitting.
He used to.
Oh yeah.
He doesn't give a fuck.
He loves it.
He loves coffee.
He used to drink it by the pot.
Just get him back on the podcast.
I missed that.
Kind of love the fuck out of that dude.
He's a great guy.
There's um,
there's a.
Why isn't the caffeine khan listed for
starbucks?
Beverage is apparently people want
caffeine.
Content is variable and starbucks
currently doesn't have any quantitative
caffeine information for all of our
beverages.
We intend on adding caffeine in
information in a future upgrade.
I love that.
We into.
We don't have the.
I'm sorry,
I don't know why.
Almost shaking.
Why am I shaking?
If I know to my coffee,
I don't know.
I wonder if they even tested like they,
even though they probably test it and
go,
what the fuck that closed the door
light.
This place on fire.
Kill everybody that saw the results.
We got to retreat and figure out what
we're going to tell people before we
come back.
I bet starbucks,
not only would they not tested,
they should find out what equipment is
used to test caffeine levels and buy
them all out and burn them.
Blow them up.
Okay.
Because it's really clear.
We are
red line people.
Fucking gills.
Oh,
I don't think we know what we're doing a
lot of stuff.
Yeah,
there's apparently there's a caffeine
database.
You can find out how much different
things have in it and uh,
it's all about milligrams per fluid
ounce.
And like say like,
if you would go with like a red bull.
Let's see if we could find red bull
here.
Some of them are crazy mad.
Holy shit.
There's something called 50 1:50
juice.
Okay.
It has 6,000
milligrams of caffeine per port,
per every 500 fluid ounces.
I tell you,
I lived mostly off just a trenta a day
and you know,
coconut water,
but
that doesn't make sense.
Well,
hold on a second.
That doesn't make any sense.
How is it 500 fluid ounces?
That's too low.
Of course it would be much larger than
everybody else's because everybody else
is like 11 fluid ounces,
six fluid ounces.
So this is 500 flu announces.
What are they doing?
And measuring it for a jug.
That's so stupid.
Why?
How the fuck did that even get included?
I can't even
because most people can't do the math to
get it done to where it needs to be.
Oh,
500,
right.
So what you're saying,
brian,
you have a trenta
I haven't yet.
I'm pretty good on caffeine nowadays.
I usually drink a trenta
and then you know,
coconut water and water most of the
most,
most of the time now.
But uh,
I've been on those five hour energy
drinks a lot lately.
Is there anything negative with drinking
those,
you know,
because they're mostly what?
Be 12?
Yeah,
no,
it'd be 12.
Was water soluble.
You piss it out if you have too much and
it's not dangerous.
It's very healthy.
B,
12 is a really good supplement.
More people should be on b.
Twelve is great for your immune system.
B,
12 is just a good all around energy
supplement.
It's so good that like and people that
work crazy hours,
video games sometimes like those guys
that are forced to work like 16 hour
days,
like many days in a row and then trying
to complete a people on sets.
They give them b,
12 shots.
It's like super,
super common.
They give you intramuscular b,
12 shots.
Then wrestlers do that.
A lot of wrestlers do that before they
compete.
They'll take like an intramuscular v12
yeah,
it's so.
It's that healthy for you.
So it's way better than starbucks
because starbucks,
I mean although it is delicious and I'm
drinking some right now,
there's a lot of fucking caffeine in
that bitch.
A venti starbucks brewed coffee ready?
A regular cup of coffee that you would
get at a diner.
The average cup of coffee and eight
ounce cup of coffee has a hundred and 80
milligrams of caffeine,
a venti starbucks has 415 as tested in
this test.
So I don't know if I'm,
you know,
this test,
who knows?
I mean,
it might've been one really strong
batch.
I don't know how many batches they
tested.
I don't know if this guy just made all
these numbers up and put it on his
websites,
which is
starbucks itself,
a caffeine free,
decaffeinated coffee that they add 12
to.
Well,
one of the things that is good idea,
but one of the things that you,
uh,
you got to remember if you say
decaffeinated decaf coffee,
has caffeine in it.
Just very small amounts.
No,
no.
It has quite a lot.
In fact,
some people say that there are decaf
coffee.
Let's,
let's find out like how much it has.
So we already established that a tall.
Okay.
Let's just a tall brewed coffee from
starbucks has 260 apoe apparently as
this guy saying.
So let's find out how much caffeine,
decaf hasn't it?
Because I know there's some in there and
it's not a little amount.
I think it'S a lot.
How much caffeine?
I can't spell.
Who told you that is what the fuck facts
that come?
No.
Does decaf starbucks out of?
I know.
I know you can't get it all out on.
It.
Needs more food for the studio.
I'll have some sun in.
what?
Do you want more of those?
a buffalo things?
No.
Is it true?
how much caffeine does decaf com
compare?
Contain?
It must.
There's no,
I guarantee you there's caffeine in
there.
So you play a lot of online pokers.
debbie noticed that there's a lot of
cheaters online.
Is there a lot of programs?
I mean,
is it even fair to play online nowadays?
is a really good question.
Um,
I'll just address that by telling you a
story.
When I was in,
I
was in the library,
you know how they have those cubicles
with computers in them.
I was walking by and I,
this was just when I got into poker and
I looked in one and there was a guy
playing poker,
so I was like,
oh,
knock on the door and see what's going
on.
Knock on the door.
He opens up,
he's playing on the computer that they
have there.
He's playing on a laptop and then
another laptop.
Now that wouldn't be that abnormal.
However,
he's playing the same six player
tournament on all three.
So he essentially cs six cards out of
52,
which gives you a gigantic advantage.
So yes,
there's shooting.
Absolutely.
So he's playing as three different
characters.
He's playing us.
Yes,
exactly.
So there's six people.
It's a call to sit and go.
So six people enter and then top to get
paid is illegal.
What are you doing?
No,
absolutely not.
No.
Wow.
So yeah,
it happens a lot.
Caffeine,
um,
content of decaf is a much less.
It says to label it decaf,
it must have at least 97 percent of the
caffeine removed.
So that leaves about five milligrams as
compared to 100 to 150 for six ounces of
brewed coffee.
They're saying 150.
The other one I think said a little bit
more,
but I think it's variable obviously.
And as they're talking about six ounces.
So that's um,
that's five milligrams.
It's not very much.
No,
I said that.
So it's definitely not going in.
But if you're sensitive to caffeine and
you drink quite a few of those,
you got to think five,
10,
15,
20,
like it started.
Now you're starting to get to a point
where you might feel it,
but as opposed to like 100 which was
like a regular cup of coffee or more.
So to a point it is broken the online
poker because you can pretty much Just
gang up on people.
so like a single new person sitting
there,
you can just pretty much play all the
other characters.
Fucking rolled again.
Yeah.
so the problem is with cash games and
with,
with smaller tournaments,
when you get bigger tournaments,
I have 10,000
players in them.
It's not such a big deal.
But yeah,
there's definitely some cheating going
on and I've,
you know,
I've had multiple times where I'm like,
there's something fishy going on here.
What about bots behind an issue?
Not really.
They can be like low stakes,
but when you get people that recognize
patterns,
good players that recognize patterns,
they're going to know you're a button,
just take advantage of it.
But when you're,
um,
I,
I heard this has been done,
I don't know if it's still being done,
but let's say if you would go into a
room and it was like a six person table,
like they're allowed to have artificial
people.
They're allowed to have,
like,
they could run a bot that's playing you.
I don't think,
uh,
it's,
it's allowed.
No,
no,
I don't think it's allowed.
I think um,
when the sites find them,
they,
they shut them down.
Okay.
So that's,
that's just misinformation.
Yeah.
So if someone says that they played
against three bots and one other dude,
it's not right?
Well,
they may have been but,
but it's not like it's not illegal.
Yeah.
You're not supposed to do that.
Where is it legal to gamble now?
Still not legal to gamble if it's an
american website,
right.
We're not allowed to play poker.
I'm home skins consulting adults.
You're not even allowed to play poker
poker with money.
Right?
We can do that still,
but only only in vegas and casinos and
casinos.
You're at home like are you allowed to
have a poker game with a bunch of your
friends and you have like stacks of
hundreds on the table and getting crazy
and drinking.
Is that illegal?
No.
Well,
yes.
The way it is,
like if,
if the house takes a rake,
it's illegal.
If you're just playing with your friends
and you know,
it seems like five bucks.
You say,
hey,
we'll play for five bucks and what have
you played for $50,000?
That's fine.
I think as long as there's no rape being
collected.
Really?
Yeah.
Is that true?
I don't actually,
I don't know that for a fact,
but I'm pretty sure that's where it is.
I feel like you would have to pay taxes
on that shit and then it's illegal,
but still have to pay taxes.
You have to,
you have to claIm the claim it.
Yeah.
That's another reason why they made it
illegal here is because the taxes were
just,
they were not being paid by a lot of
people because it's based off shore.
It was based in Ireland,
uh,
england and Costa Rica.
What were the three big assignment?
Isn't that a,
you know,
irs problem?
How could they deny the entire.
I mean,
it seems like as a technology issue,
how could you deny an entire industry
they weren't getting paid off.
It's about the money.
They're not getting revenue because the
sites are based offshore,
so they're only getting revenue when
people pay their taxes.
People that have sites on shore and then
make the money from that and then say,
yeah,
and then say if you have an offshore
when you have to pay taxes on it or
we'll get you.
Listen,
there's a lot of thIngs in this world
that just don't make any sense.
I could fix so much.
Just simple logic,
logic.
Hey listen,
I mean it's,
it's incredibly terrible that I have to
play.
I mean,
I like Mexico.
I'm right on the beach.
It's beautiful.
There's a lot of dolphins swimming by,
but like that where you live right now?
Yeah,
I'm live in Mexico.
I have a house.
He lives there too,
right?
Jc still live in Mexico city?
I think so,
yeah.
So you live in Mexico near the beach.
You don't say where because they will
come get you.
They'll know about.
I live right on the beach.
It's beautiful.
I love listening to the way as I go to
sleep.
It's awesome.
But I miss a lot of,
a lot of things about the states,
like the law,
the law,
the food was a lot of things I missed,
you know.
Um.
Have you ever seen any crazy shit living
in Mexico?
Have you seen some things that have made
you go,
oh,
okay,
we're not in Kansas anymore.
One of the first days I was there,
I went for a run on the beach and
there's um,
like a,
a cliff and it's kind of a secluded on
one end and there were two people just
banging it out rigHt there hanging out
sexually.
Oh yeah,
that's fine.
That was fine.
But no,
as far as like weird things,
I mean,
did you watch,
did you sit there and let them finish?
I was looking right in his eyes.
What I'm saying is you don't see,
you don't see very many like crime
situation.
No,
I don't put myself in positions to be in
that.
I basically stay in the resort the whole
time.
I mean I go out to go and get food.
So you live in a resort?
Yeah,
basically they have like pools and
tennis courts,
basketball courts and stuff like that.
So you just stay in the resort base.
Wow.
So you're like living in an apartment?
Yeah.
That's surrounded by a whole nother
country that you don't venture into
basically.
Whoa.
I go in like probably I would say twice
a week.
That's a true.
Are you a,
what's called an ex pat?
Are you like an official ex pat?
I wouldn't consider myself an ex pat.
But you live in Mexico?
Well I have a house in vegas.
I own a house.
Oh.
So I rented it out while I go to Mexico
and play.
Wow,
that's cool.
So you have to be in Mexico to do this.
I can't put like if I was right here and
I tried to fire it up,
it wouldn't let me.
The ip will be blocked.
Wow.
And not only that,
but now there's millions and millions of
dollars that's doj has seized from full
tilt poker.
That's just sitting there.
We haven't been paid that back yet.
so what they basically did was they shut
the site's down.
It was,
I think it was um,
April 15th,
something like that.
They shut all the sites down and if you
had money online deck went to the doj
and now you have to sub.
You have to ask them for your money back
and we still can't get our money back.
Oh wow.
Good.
Be creepy government.
It is.
Yep.
Creepy fucking government,
man.
I,
I'm just baffled that,
you know,
against other consenting adults.
I can't play poker with them.
Well,
it's really gross.
We allow grown adults to tell us what we
can and can't do when it comes to
situations like this that is not in.
That is not.
That's not a tax issue because it should
be completely unrelated.
How how you pay your taxes should be
your personal responsibility based on
what your actually income is.
Absolutely.
If you want to hide your gambling
income,
they should be able to find out or you
only make $50,000
a year.
How do you have a $300,000
car?
So oh,
let's go online.
See this motherfucker plays poker all
day and he's not reporting his winnings
like I'm all for that.
I think everybody should have to pay
their share,
but you shouldn't be able to tell me
what I can do.
That's stupid.
I agree.
I know.
You can see.
Look,
you can google anyone's name and see
what they've won.
It's just,
it's out there.
It's all.
It's all public because when you cash in
a tournament,
it shows it online.
Yeah.
You know what about didn't know what was
it filled?
Full tilt poker that got busted for
fraud,
who got busted for fraud?
Absolute poker,
absolute poker.
What would they do?
They had a guy that basically could see
your whole cards,
like an admin,
but yeah,
he liked recreated some kind of.
I dunno,
I'm not very computer savvy,
but something that he could see every
card at the table and what he was doing
was he was just winning these insane
amounts of money and not even trying to
hide it.
LIke for example,
uh,
when he won a tournament,
he made a call at the last one,
the last car.
The river came out with 10 high.
I don't know if you play poker,
not,
but basically a call that you would net
that I've never met in my life.
Okay.
Right.
Never because it's never good.
and he was right because he could see
the guys cards,
but it's like,
how are you going to be that blatant
about it?
If you could see that,
why would you not just play cool a
little bit more discreet.
Exactly.
Get third in the tournament once.
Maybe he's in prison now or is he does
the thing.
Man,
there's the grid,
there's so much gray area with,
with poker and law,
so he's,
he's not in jail.
Well,
there was that guy who was trying to run
an mma organization as well.
That bodog guy,
calvin era.
Was it?
YEs.
Yeah,
yeah.
He had like this whole thing that he was
doing.
Well,
he was having these guys like fight on
the beach and you know,
this beautiful resort in Costa Rica or
something like that.
you know,
he put the fights
like,
um,
the beach.
I saw his house.
I was in Costa Rica.
Golfing was on the golf course.
He's a baller.
He's a powerful baller,
but he's forced to live in another
country.
He can't come to America.
He comes to America.
He'd be arrested.
That'd be arrested.
Him and dana white where they had like
this big go back and forth.
it was pretty hilarious.
Twitter are longtime before twitter,
before on websites and interviews and
stuff like that.
But he had like his picture,
like he would have these built bull
billboards with like him in a beautiful
suit with girls behind him.
Calvin,
I or presents put dog fights like what a
solid man is selling.
You looking like a pimp,
but unsexy.
He's selling the lifestyle.
That's what people are fascinated by
that not just fascinated by the fights.
They're fascinated by his lifestyle,
but he was forced into exile because of
online gambling.
Right.
And the crazy part about it is,
is a,
you can still gamble on horses,
but you can get them on the lottery.
The lottery scratch tickets are
available at every gas station and
that's chance poker is skill.
I've had eight years of.
I've had one losing year out of eight
years.
Yeah.
But that's,
uh,
yeah,
that's rare.
That wasn't it.
Yeah.
The three percent of people will make
money playing poker.
Three percent,
three percent.
That's similar to professional pool and
fighting as well.
Yeah.
The top guys.
How many comedians?
Pretty much everything and pretty much
everything.
Yeah.
Right.
It makes it real.
If it's real money.
Yeah.
Ditch diggers often,
like,
I think they all get the same amount for
them.
Dolphin,
sex doesn't even make sense,
bro.
Like,
how many times do people hang out with
dolphins and not fuck them?
Probably three percent.
How many are successful that try to fuck
them?
That would be what it would be.
No,
because dolphins want to fuck back to
shut the fuck up.
Stop read it.
Can't be able to talk to you.
Can't believe I just engaged you back,
brought you back into the full pitch.
Um,
yeah.
Most,
most poker players,
what do they do to make a living?
It's what I do.
It's the only thing I do,
but most don't.
Most.
Well I can't speak for everyone else.
I know that there's probably maybe 50
guys I can name them.
Make good money.
I mean there's some guys that make
stupid money and they have like they,
they,
they're always into crazy bets.
Like they'll play golf for a million
dollars or something.
Yeah.
Pretty normal isn't the top one percent
that is so fucking crazy.
It is.
To play a round of golf for a million
bucks.
But that's so normal,
isn't it?
Will you do those guys for them?
Yeah.
I don't bet a million dollars.
Have you ever had a crazy bad about
something like who's going to lose the
most about a way to take the longest
shit or because that's the kind of
things they bet on.
Right?
I could ship the longest complete shit
ever.
We bet on a lot of weird things.
Like we bet one time we met a guy that
he wouldn't take a shot glass full of
like steak rub.
Hello?
Yeah,
he was a lot.
A little water.
He did you know that that guy could die
if that's all salt.
I did not know that.
I think if you eat like a pound of salt,
you could die.
I guess the shot glass is not a pound
shot glass,
but be submitted in that stake rep is
like more granulated space in between.
It's not as heavY as like morton salt.
Right?
Like if you drank a shot glass of morton
salt,
that would be impressive as fuck it.
Let's dig.
rob's not quite heavy.
Like a.
That's like a.
If you can stay in a pool for 24 hours,
things like that.
The state in a pool for 24 hours.
Who did that?
I don't remember his name,
but he did take probably because he died
in that pool.
Um,
what about that guy?
Do you know him?
The famous gambler in vegas that
actually got breast implants?
Do you know that story?
I think I remember seeing that a while
ago on tv.
Um,
he wore them for a whole year.
That was the,
that was the bet.
I don't know him personally.
Isn't a legendary.
Isn't that guy legendary character?
What's his name?
We're gOing.
I can tell you if he isn't telling me
his name had been on the show poker
after dark.
Nope.
Have not been on that.
I was on um,
one of the espn,
a world series poker ones.
that's cool.
Yeah.
Actually like watching that show,
what is the,
the most success you've had with poker?
You mean like most one in a day or
something?
Or most one like,
you know,
ever $100,000.
The guy won.
He won $100,000.
Looking at him there.
What was his name?
Brian zen.
I don't know.
I've never cashed in on $100,000.
Bet by getting breast implants for a
year.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Eight years later he still has them.
Are you serious?
You keep them?
Yeah.
See,
I think I would keep them too.
I think after a couple months he'd be
like,
dude,
it's fucking high.
I had really nice tits.
Boobs are awesome.
I don't think that's what it is.
I think he probably does it because he's
nuts.
As far as a.
I can tell you the most I've lost in the
day.
It was 25 k wow.
That's kind.
Suck it and that really sucked.
But the wind was two.
Oh,
nine in a day.
Two hundred 9,000
g's.
Louisa,
what did you.
What's the first thing you bought?
Did you buy any?
I bought a lexus.
Nice.
Nice for cash.
Yeah,
it's quick.
that's a good car too,
because that's sounded like stepping out
of line.
Not getting crazy.
Didn't go bentley.
No,
no.
You bought like a sense of car.
That's a nice car that's out there right
now.
I love that car.
It's really reliable.
I love it.
That's the thing about lexis,
man.
Those things are bulletproof.
I had one of those big trucks as qx,
whatever the fuck it was.
Amazing car man there.
So well designed to.
Yeah,
they have that new one.
They have the new version of the ls
there.
They're big flagship sedan.
It might as well be a spaceship mean it.
Parks itself hit a button and it
parallel parks for you.
Like that has been nana's.
It's crazy.
The fucking thing.
Actually.
Parks for you.
Cameras in the front,
cameras in the rear,
you know all this different shit that
makes it run perfect.
So it's amazing how like computer
control and all these things.
Oh my god,
I can't wait until five to 10 years from
now will be the google car.
The car that's driving around now.
That's going to suck.
Dude.
I'm going to lose all your fucking fun.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's true.
It should be that.
You should have the option to do it that
way.
fuck that way.
or it's just on a table.
you should
be able to have the option to either
have the google car.
Not like being able to almost like ride
a train.
Like I just want to be fun for long
trips,
like a five hour drive and just sit
there with your ipad or watch a movie.
You wouldn't be able to avoid all the
other crazy assholes.
It didn't have google cars.
It's true.
Can switching lanes and shit and make it
even hit the brakes.
You'd probably be sitting there with no
seatbelt to get in an accident.
You're probably not.
The lag is.
I wonder if they ever figure out that
this accidents that are caused by the
google car that w or caused because the
google car couldn't respond as quickly
or as precisely as a person could where
there was options.
Google car,
car trolls.
The shitty option.
I'm done with engines,
bro.
I'm like living right now.
I like this right now.
Oh yeah.
I think we get to enjoy this.
Well,
allegedly I took that car up to 1:40.
Oh,
allegedlY.
That's scary.
Fast.
That's like,
that's a wheel fall off fast feeling.
No.
Well it's interesting because I'm
allegedly.
I also took my old saab up to $100.
It was shaking.
Yeah.
This one was clean.
It's big difference,
man.
Those japanese engineers,
they're not fucking playing games.
We're not playing around.
There's a.
Have you ever seen that one crazy lexis
that they held the ls lf lfo?
Lfo.
Elephants lfa and say yeah,
jesus,
they had one and um,
when I went to vegas to get my car
serviced,
they have one in the showroom and I was
just like a half a million dollars.
Yeah,
it's,
yeah,
I think they stopped making them though
and they only had a certain amount.
Yeah,
I think they made like $300.
How much was it?
300.
I think it's super duper expensive,
but it was just weird that it was like
performance wise,
it wasn't really much better than a
nissan gtr if better at all that she saw
something where they raised those two,
I think.
And it was pretty comparable.
Yeah.
Gtr is a $100,000
car and it's a monster and that's
another same coin.
That's an insane piece of engineering
and it's also something that apparently
nissan doesn't really even make any
money on it.
They just wanted to prove a point.
It's really kind of a country move.
They're like put out a better car,
cheaper and like deal with it.
They're like,
your prices are way too high.
We're going to bring them down like good
luck for rory.
How much is that thing?
$300,000
to come up with that number.
I want to know how they come up with
that number,
how much it costs.
You ever seen it?
Ferrari factory does.
They're artisans.
They're big difference between like a
ferrari and a like just if you're going
to buy a ferrari,
you're going to buy something that's
made by craftsmen like the leather
stitching.
The dash has done by hand.
The car's engines pieced together by a
bunch of specialists.
TheY all do it in this gigantic,
beautiful,
clean warehouse where they eat espresso
at lunch and take two hour naps and
these are like artists and they put
together these,
these machines that are.
They're not just beautiful and not just
like perfect engineering,
but it sounded.
They can construct it like there's just
like a feeling to them like,
like if you're into watches and he pick
up a rolex and feel the automatic timer
and know that someone like put all that
shit together,
there's something to mechanical things
that are created by the human hand that
makes him like really special to us and
you don't really get that with the gtr.
You do.
I mean it is designed by man and put
together.
But what you get,
it's like this feeling of this crazy
technological marvel like you get in it
and you feel like,
you know the lights come on though.
The,
the,
the engine revs up.
You hear the turbines like whoa.
Like this is a fucking spaceship.
This thing is a,
some,
some crazy piece of the most advanced
automobile technology available,
but it doesn't feel like an old ferrari.
Like if you started up and he had a bomb
and you realize some of the italian
dudes built this thing and stitch these
seats together by hand.
You know when you pull the seatbelt,
it's all.
Someone made all this shit.
You know,
you feel that leather steering wheel and
like everything's mechanical and moving
the shifter and hearing the clickety
clack.
There's something about like,
man created things that in my opinion is
like,
it's like art in a physical form that's
functional and that you use,
you know,
and there's this.
Whenever someone tells me like,
oh,
don't even like cars.
You know,
cars are stupid to me.
A car's just gets you where you want to
go.
Okay.
Have you ever driven a shelby mustang?
Do you even know what the fuck you're
talking about?
You,
you don't,
you don't like that feeling when you hit
the gas and you hear and feel those
fucking tires squeaking a little bit
because they're trying to get some
traction because there's so much fucking
horsepower
then you're not alive,
man.
You're not alive.
You really need a prius.
You got to try that one.
So at least it's a good feeling.
It is a good feeling.
Amazing.
Especially when you do standard because
then you really feel like you're part of
the car.
That I'll make that lexis so standard.
Even though the wall that I can bring it
in and I can actually do up and down
with the shifter,
but it's not the same because you know,
you don't have the feet.
That's like being a little kid in high
school.
It does not drive a stick shift and you
pretending to shifting the gears and
your role and exactly what it is and it
won't even actually there's a,
there's things put in place where you
can't,
it'll,
um,
gear up even if you don't.
Because if you could take it to a
certain point.
So it's not really real.
Yeah.
It's bullshit.
My m three has that.
They have a doubles watch.
Yeah.
It's nice and it's great for traffic.
Sure.
You know,
and it's,
it,
it's way more efficient
than you would ever be with a clutch.
So clutch is kind of stupid in the long
run,
but this is that mechanical feeling.
Again,
the thing of shifting your own gears and
turning on,
stealing,
steering wheel,
there's a thrill to that that like,
it feels good.
It's not even about speeding,
you know,
like have you ever driven one of those
really old porsches and I was like 19
seventies,
like 69,
70,
71.
It was really tiny little mechanical
things.
they have the engine in the back.
It's all screwy.
It hit too much gas.
He goes side with,
but they only have like 150 horsepower.
They're not heavy.
The reallY light,
but you feel everything in that thing
and you get out.
Even if you're going 40 miles an hour,
you get out of the car with a big smile
on your face.
Like that was fucking cool.
There's some,
we've lost something.
It takes a lot more to get us to that
feeling in like some crazy technological
marvel like alexa.
Yes.
Yeah.
I think it's more like you're,
you feel lIke you're,
you're actually doing something in the
cars,
not just driving for you.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You're,
yeah,
exactly.
Moving it along this car.
I mean,
I don't even know what someone's buttons
do and they're just like,
yeah.
When you find out about traction control
and stability control and like they
literally,
they're going around a corner.
If one wheel starts spinning,
they'll hit,
they'll apply brakes to it and like only
break one wheel and turned the car this
way to try to balance it out.
It'll turn you out a fishtails yeah,
it's amazing.
Especially that gtr gtr is incredible
for that.
Like all the guys who review it,
they,
you know,
they'll joke around about taking on a
race track,
just trying to throw it into the corners
and the car just figures out how to do
it and corrects itself.
Which is really smart.
You don't want some asshole in some 1970
porsche.
That's gonna fucking kick out sideways
on him.
EverY time he goes around a corner and
gives it the gas.
You don't want that.
You want that asshole to drive the gtr.
But then in order for him to get his
asshole kicks,
he's got to go a lot faster.
You got to go a lot faster.
One 40,
you've got to hit that gas,
feel,
that fucking thing.
Oh,
I just had my.
I'm leaving my car out here because it
kind of sticks out there,
you know,
so I drive my roommate's car and it's
just such a treat to get back here and
drive this thing.
What kind of cars?
I thought,
oh my roommates or my room as his was
like a corolla.
I'm like a 92.
I think somewhere around there.
You don't want to drive his fucking car
while I do out there because it's
getting a push.
They do that in Mexico.
Mexico.
Yeah.
That's a good move because I don't want
to attract attention to that.
Yeah.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
I thought you meant like here and.
yeah.
I was like,
hmm.
People love my scars here.
No,
here is fine.
Yeah,
I'm in Mexico.
Like if you have like a mercedes or you
a target.
Yeah,
I think they say the guy that was
helping me move in,
like the landlord was like,
hey,
you can take your car here.
There's,
there's mercedes.
And so he's such a.
I saw like one mercedes in the garage.
And was he sweating?
The one who's just fucking would be
looking around the corner.
Look,
I'm looked at everyone's stairs
whenever,
wherever I go in Mexico.
So I would just imagine how it would be
if they saw a spaceship.
So how often do you go out?
You said you don't really leave the
resort.
How often do you mean grocery?
Grocery shopping.
Like,
oh,
you want to leave to go grocery
shopping,
but that's just highway and then grocery
store and then highway back.
It's not that bad to go there and
there's dudes with arrows and machine
guns and shit and.
Oh yeah,
they have w.
There's guys with machine guns all over
the place.
The police?
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
they just carry around machine.
I was like,
it's no big deal.
It's crazy.
That is different.
Would be the case?
No,
they clamPed down a bit.
From what I understand.
Um,
it's more of a,
it's more police now than it was a
little while ago.
Well,
like when I first started going,
the first time I went to Mexico I think
was pre 2000 I think.
I think I might've went.
No,
it was when I was on mtv,
I was on this thing for fear factor and
we did it,
so it must have been like 2001 or 2002.
It was pretty much safe.
Yeah,
it's pretty normal.
It's pretty safe.
I think a lot of the things that they
show here,
just like the worst of the worst and
it's like you can find that anywhere.
Right.
You know,
look,
there's murders here too.
You know what I mean?
It's just,
they're not publicized as much as they
are.
It's hard to get the video.
The video of those guys put out with
their fucking crazy narco music over it.
When I show people getting machine gun
shit,
they have that.
oh,
there's some videos of them chopping
people up with chainsaws.
yeah,
they've done a really mean shit.
It's really not.
That's not,
that's not very nice.
Yeah.
We got to figure out how to fix that
problem.
Everybody's worrIed about Iraq and
Afghanistan.
We live next to one of the craziest
spots on earth.
Look,
they can't get clean water,
man.
It's crazy.
We got to go out and refill our water.
We can't use the water in the sink.
Really can do the mexicans use it.
Yeah,
but you get sick for a long time if you
do it,
but eventually you get used to it,
which I mean develops a good bacteria.
It goes back to that fecal transplants.
Shit.
Well you need to do is get a mexican
dude shit and your butt and uh,
his fecal matter will balance out your
ecosystem.
I'll look into that.
That's a real thing,
man.
When we were talking about earlier,
yeah,
I,
I actually googled it and it's called a,
they call it fecal microbiota
transplantation,
also known as a stool transplants
process of transporting fecal bacteria
from a healthy individual into a
recipient as a treatment for patients
suffering for them from a cdi,
which is a,
which produces effects ranging from
diarrhea to a pseudo membrane.
Ious colitis.
Colitis is not good.
Anytime someone says he got colitis.
Previous terms for the procedure include
fecal bacteriotherapy,
fecal transfusion.
Fecal transplant,
huh?
Wow.
They wIll involve restoration of the
colonic flora by introducing healtHy
bacterial flora through an infusion of
stool.
People just eat better.
Well,
the fact that someone came up with this
idea,
yeah,
who,
someone's pretty mixed in there one day
and just saying,
I wonder if we can put poop in someone
else's buttons,
fix their.
Well,
they're starting to understand so much
more when it comes to bacteria and
healthy bacteria and they're starting to
understand that it,
it affects mood.
It's affects behavior,
it affects so much and it wards off
diseases and improves your immune system
and actually some bacteria aggressively
fights off colds and aggressively fights
off when you come into contact with a
certain different,
you know,
nasty things that they can actually be
like having troops and your body does.
Don't,
don't viruses just mutate and come back
stronger though.
Well,
they couldn't.
If you don't take your fucking men's do
all 10 days.
If you're one of those bitches like doug
stanhope who openly admitted on the
podcast that he contributed to the
creation of a super aids by not taking
his fucking full z-pak.
Yeah.
He's one of those dudes.
I have felt better.
I stopped tagging it.
So,
uh,
so if somebody tries to tell you that,
that they took that your shit is so good
that you took it out and put it in
someone's body and it healed them,
you know,
the guy might not be lying.
Sounds like
he'd be a bullshit artist that does
sound,
no pun intended.
So,
um,
how did you get involved with being a,
like a sort of an expert on positive
thinking or mental concentration?
Or did you just get it by experimenting
yourself?
And tHen I met someone in a poker game a
while ago in la.
We were running a poker in la.
Was it already should fear?
No,
and a guy's kind of taken me under his
wing,
kind of taught me the ways of life
really.
How much gay sex is involved in a lot.
A lot.
It seems.
It seems like you've just given none.
No.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it's been,
it's just something I've always known in
my life.
Just there's,
there's something I got to learn,
you know,
I got to learn about myself.
I got to learn how to think,
how to feel,
how to,
how to just be man.
I mean there was a lot of time,
like for example,
with women,
I would not talk to a woman for till I
college.
I was scared of rejection and one day I
choose the music.
Brian.
Yeah.
We're gonna.
Need you to repeat this story?
Okay.
So what you were saying basically that
there was one really big breakup.
Yes.
It's one really big,
crazy heart wrenching breakup.
It wasn't really that big though.
Okay.
For the story.
For this store.
Oh,
that's right.
For the hulk music while I'm trying to
stall while brian pulls up the hold
music.
the internet here sucks it.
Hmm.
Shocker.
Anyway,
go ahead and tell us your story.
No,
look,
I wouldn't even go up to a woman because
I was scared of rejection and one day I
was sitting there,
I was like,
why am I scared of this rejection?
And I thought to myself like,
if I don't go up,
it's a no right every time.
And if you just close your eyes and jerk
off in the bathroom,
it's a yes every time.
It's like you pretended to actually
happen and then you can talk to where
without needing something,
without being such a needy bitch,
and you probably wind up being more
successful.
Well look,
that's one of the things I've learned is
like everything is created By yourself.
You're as confident as you believe you
can be as weak as you believe you are.
I saw your twitter.
It was really funny.
Yeah,
I do.
Um,
text message you the wrong person.
And so he,
uh,
he text messaged me,
hey,
you got the wrong number and this is
matt and hey,
by the way,
girls don't like it when you need it.
Exactly.
Well,
he texted,
he texted me three times within an hour
and I was sitting there playing poker
and I was just like,
man,
stop annoying me.
And I was like,
you know what?
No,
I'm just going to help this guy out.
Listen,
you cannot text the girl three times.
She's done with you after the second
text probably.
Yeah.
Even the second text you've given up
your cards,
you know,
what are you doing?
But unless you're just having fun and
not have to worry about anything,
you're not actually playing a game of
trying to catch the pussy.
Yeah.
You know,
if you could be friends and you could
send three text to a friend.
Sure.
But let's be realistic trying to get
some blue cards.
It's the same as poker.
Right?
You get crazy.
You throw all your money on the table
and you're fucked.
Yeah.
Requires discipline.
Well,
in the big,
in the beginning I went broke three
times.
Broke,
like sucking dicks on the street.
No,
well,
I mean I was still living with my
parents so it wasn't that bad.
But you were living with your parents
and he went broke.
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
wait,
hold on.
Let me think about.
It is a long time ago.
If you'Re going to make up a story,
have it made up.
Okay.
I don't want to hear you crazy.
Fake going broke with your parents.
I went broke when I was in college in
college,
so like when I was in,
I went to plattsburgh,
upstate New York and I went broke like
three times during that period I went
broke with my student loan first.
Oh jesus.
So like,
and then I,
I made six grand back and I went to
vegas and I made,
I made some money,
but I was like trying to be that cool
guy going to clubs and spending all this
money and I went home with like 200
bucks every time I went broke I
rebounded within a week and I got back.
I had a 9,000
score.
Right.
So you have been addicted to playing
poker for a long fucking time.
You're talking about like,
I wouldn't say dictate the wrong
terminology.
You been,
uh,
an extreme enthusiasts of,
of competitive poker.
Yeah.
Well,
the way it went was the first year I
learned how to play.
I was playing eight hours a day,
seven days a week.
You just got obsessed.
That's the way I am when I do something
and I really put my mind to it.
I want to be the best.
There's just no stopping.
So,
and it,
with poker it's much like with a lot of
other disciplines,
there's so much you can learn that it
becomes really exciting.
Like the more you know more effort and
focus,
you Put on it,
the more you read about it,
the more you improve and you see that
improvement.
It's very stimulating,
you know,
it is.
And,
and the great thing about poker,
the I love is it's always new,
new things always.
You can pick up something new every time
you play.
And that's why I love it because it
keeps me learning new things every day
and,
and growing as a poker player,
you know,
as a personal that stuff.
Well it seems like it'd be a fun way to
make a living too,
as long as you're actually successful.
But that one year you said you had like
one year they did it last year.
Data a soccer bag one.
Yeah.
Well,
most of the reason was because I lost my
online income because of the black
friday poker being coming illegal so I
couldn't play on line,
so I was just spending money without
making it.
So.
Is that why you moved to Mexico?
partially,
yeah.
Make more money.
Do you find yourself a little.
Can you read it down there that knows
how to speak spanish and get you out of
a jam?
No,
no,
I haven't.
I don't.
I can't speak spanish at all.
You live in,
in spanish,
you can't speak spanish.
Most of them are part of the problem.
Most of the big restaUrants and stuFf
speak english,
so I never really had the better.
We're right next door.
We've got the Cash.
Exactly.
You got the guns now.
They got the guns now.
We sold them a lot of guns.
A lot of guns.
Man.
That was one of the dumbest ideas in the
history of the human race.
Was that operation fast and furious.
You know,
that is when the dea decided to.
We've got to find out where there's
mexicans do with these guns,
sell them a bunch of guns,
track them.
So they sold them like thousands of
guns.
Scroll the operation fast and furious.
Yeah,
it's a real.
And then some of those guns were
actually used to kill a us border patrol
agent like that is easily one of the
dumbest ideas in the history of the.
Or one of the most clever ruses for.
Oh,
I was just so stupid.
I didn't even know you can't sell guns.
Whips.
Sorry.
I won't happen again.
I was actually working for the good
guys.
And now selling the bad guys guns.
Yeah,
I figured we'd Just watch who they shoot
and then we have them.
You get it.
We have about 2000 guns over there.
No worries.
It's no big deal in guns are illegal
over there in Mexico.
All guns?
No.
We'll illegal to own as as a citizen.
Like what about rifles?
Like hunting rifles.
I don't know about that.
I think that would be a gun,
right?
I mean that's stupid.
How are you supposed to kill your food?
You don't have to.
Everybody has to rely on someone else to
kill it for them.
Apparently beans are already dead,
bro.
They're alive.
You got to pick them,
bitch trying to out there.
MaYbe you do.
But um,
yeah,
it's,
it's real interesting living out there,
man.
It's,
it's a new world.
So You moved there just to specifically
to get around this law?
Yeah.
ARe you in trouble like saying that?
Can you say.
Oh no,
no,
no.
It's legal to play there.
Oh,
it is?
Yeah.
It's legal.
Is it legal?
So you can say,
like if someone says,
hey,
Why are you living in Mexico?
You can say,
look,
I'm a professional poker player.
That's how I make my living.
You paid taxes in America on those ill
gotten gains.
Yeah.
That's illegal.
And how is that not illegal?
It's,
I don't know.
It's where the actual house that you
sleep in is settled in.
that's what's important.
What line of the dirt isn't on?
yup.
if it's on here,
you can go to jail.
If it's on here,
they'll take your tax dollars.
That's how it is.
You get shit for going back and forth
like the border guys look at you.
Funny.
Not really.
I mean I just say them there to surf and
relaxed.
Which is true.
Do you sit?
Does it say that you're a,
that you live like on you looking at
your passport,
does it say you live in Mexico?
No,
a United States passport.
Yeah.
So what do you say?
Just say I have a vacation home down
there.
I just say vacationing.
Yeah.
And you know,
it's not really a deal,
a big deal when you come into the us,
but when you go into Mexico you don't
want to say that.
What's the deal with Canada?
Can you do that in Canada?
You could do in Canada.
Yeah.
You chose Mexico or Canada?
Yeah,
like the beach dude.
True.
That's true.
I guess dc.
Those photos of a.
Kevin perry was in cabo and then photos
he sent either tweeting.
It's just looks so beautiful.
So gorgeous.
It was fucking gorgeous.
however you might get shot Canada.
Canadians are way nicer.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I thought about it,
you know,
but I just want to go somewhere and make
a bunch of money and come back and live
now.
Do you,
when you have a professional poker
player,
like what's the longterm goal?
Do you like?
You try to be the best,
try to like stockpile enough money away
so that you can get through a bad year.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
for example,
I bought a house last year,
you know,
um,
I just try to,
I have some money with a financial
advisor.
I have some money in my bank,
you know,
I just try to diversify
because there are going to be rainy days
where you don't make money.
so,
you know,
I was fortunate that I was able to make
enough to not have to really worry about
it when black friday hit and you know,
I could,
I could live.
it's funny that eVerybody calls it in
the poker community friday,
black friday,
black friday.
Is there,
is there any work being done and try to
fix that.
Yeah,
that's going on I would say about a year
until it's legalized.
But the problem lies,
the problem now is that they want to do
it state to state where you're not gonna
be able to play with the whole world.
So you're going to have.
It's not going to be able to make as
much money as you could,
you know,
just to play against californians.
But that's the job bitches.
That's true.
On a,
on sunday they have a $200 buy in,
which gets about 4,000
players.
You can win a quarter of a million
dollars.
Where's this?
It's online.
Jesus.
pokerstars.
And you can't play it if you live in
America.
Correct.
To try to go.
Could you go through a proxy or as you
could but then like a pierogi but not as
tasty.
You could.
Yeah,
you could.
But I wouldn't say.
I mean,
I wouldn't suggest it,
you know,
because if they catch you,
I don't know what they would do.
So it probably arrest you.
Right?
I don't know.
Well that's what I said.
The law with poker is it's so new that
they don't really have anything set in
place.
So they could probably take your money.
Probably.
Isn't that funny?
They can't take it.
If you do it in Mexico,
even though you're paying them the taxes
on that.
If you do that,
that's one of the worst part of it.
Please is that,
well finally they just remedy this,
but for a bunch of years you couldn't
carry over losses.
So let's say you made 100 k one year,
but then the next year he lost 40 and
they're not giving you any of the 100
back.
So it's hard to survive sometimes.
Will that just makes sense.
I mean it's just based on a yearly
thing.
Yeah.
Do you think that you'd be able to.
Well,
because like for example,
if you're a doctor you're making around
the same each year,
but if you're a poker player you can
lose some,
some urine,
you know,
now you can carry over though.
They let you now carry over.
Oh,
you do now you can as the last.
Within the last year I believe.
Oh,
that's interesting.
I should say I was told this by
somebody,
the same guy that told brian that
dolphins have,
but no,
this was a cpa,
so I'm hoping it's right or else I'm
screwed.
He's a producer.
There are distributors of
disinformation.
Make sure you check.
Yeah,
I should check the same.
You never know man.
You're right.
It might be fucking with you.
It's true.
Next thing you know,
you're trying to claim some shit and
he's trying to get you locked up.
Maybe he's deep inside.
He's working from the inside like that
show homeland and I'm talking about.
I haven't seen it yet.
I've been told to watch that though.
It's good man.
So,
um,
you said you worked with camp men and
you work with commonly?
Yes.
You work with conference last five
franklin.
So.
Well actually I worked with him for his
last fight before that,
against more extensively for the other
fight.
We talked once.
Oh,
so we didn't.
It's sort of like still in its infancy
stages.
Are you planning on doing this as a
business?
I want to know what would you do?
Just make different programs based on
different guys and how just play it by
ear and try to figure out how what we
can do to fix them.
Yeah,
I mean,
well,
the thing is,
like I said,
it differs so much from person
to person so you can have kind of an
idea of where you're going,
but how you get there is going to be
different based on everybody else and
what they're.
What's going on in their head.
That's pretty cool,
dude.
You know,
you're obviously a guy who's a sort of
figured out in life that you can carve
your own path.
You know,
you don't have.
You're not living,
you're living in fucking Mexico.
First of all,
that's be a big hand professional poker
player and I'm just going to go mentally
coach fighters.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean that's,
that's the fun way to live life I think.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
I think it's so important for people to
hear that people like you are doing that
too because so many people think that
life is just this sort of mundane series
of events that you've been thrown into
and there's no way to get out of it and
you're going to be stuck doing
something.
This,
You know,
along these lines for the rest of your
life.
Like you can do anything you want,
and I know it sounds corny,
but one day I literally woke up and
said,
you know what?
I want to work with them.
May flyers and I,
and I Took action.
You know,
that's the best.
The one thing I think that most people
are lacking.
They can think of great things they want
to do,
but as far as action goes,
a lot of people are waiting for someone
else to come along and help them.
You know?
That's why it's one of the most annoying
things I bet you must get this,
is people that have requests for you to
help them start a business or requests
for you to help them.
Do you get that kInd of investor?
You mean as an investor?
I've been burned a couple of times.
I don't do it anymore.
You can't.
You've got to figure out your own pants
on,
you know,
and coming up to someone and say,
listen,
if you took this and brought it to a
producer,
like,
ah,
I got my own things to worry about.
You've got to find your own way.
Don't,
don't try to get a bunch of people to
fucking make your business by donating
money and stop fap.
You need to set up a structure that you
need to just set up a structure for how
you're going to get to where you want to
get,
and that's the only way to do it.
There's a lot of fucking people that
want other people to help them.
I get requests like that.
Can you teach me how to play poker?
That seems easy.
It's like,
do you realize how much time it takes to
get good at poker?
I asked them that.
I say,
do you understand that you're going to
have to be completely immersed in it for
a year or two.
Can you do that with your time?
Eight hours a day?
Good luck,
and if you don't,
you're gonna lose.
Exactly.
So he never be a fucking professional.
God dammit.
It's verY important though,
do to have guys like you to have a
conversation with someone who's living a
life that seems like a crazy life.
Like you know,
like,
wow,
that guy figured that out.
How that to do that,
it's so important for normal folks too.
To hear stuff like your story.
Like if I was 18 and I heard your story,
it would be great for me because I'd be
like,
oh,
okay,
well that's possible too.
Like maybe you don't have to do this
job.
Like maybe I should figure out if I
could be a poker player.
That guy seems cool.
He's having a good time.
Like just the idea.
Just put the idea of you being able to
accomplish things that are unusual.
Things you don't see around you.
It's not easy.
It takes work and that's why most people
I don't think do it because it takes a
lot of work,
man.
It takes a lot of work to do anything to
do any of you to be an mma fighter,
to be a poker player and anything and
everything.
That's sort of the key to life.
Find something that you really love to
do and just go fucking crazy with it
and the key is to not be stopped because
you're going to hit road bumps and some
people will just say,
okay,
well I'll try something new,
but you know,
I hit road bumps in poker too when I'm
broke,
you know,
you didn't.
I thought about quitting every time,
you know,
and I just said,
you know what,
I'm just going to get better.
And I actually with the way I did it was
I messages the top 10 ranked poker
players online.
That's how I did it.
I said,
listen,
I'm looking to get good.
Will you take five minutes out of your
day to talk to me?
And three of them said,
yes,
those are suckers.
Those guys screwed up.
Sudden let this guy in nice take all
your fucking money.
What have you come in second place in
you,
you come in first place.
And he comes in second and he's like,
what the fuck?
Yeah,
you certainly can't do it with a large
group of people,
but I definitely try to take like three
or four people under my wing,
you know,
at a time.
That's cool man.
I think it's important to know brian
under your wing.
I've been life cooked so much this week
from sore.
I can't even say.
And with that,
ladies and gentlemen,
thanks.
Once again.
Anybody
who bought my special,
my comedy special online,
if you go to joe rogan.net
live from the tabernacle,
I couldn't come up with another name.
I was trying to figure out what another
name would be,
but it just never came to me and I
didn't think it was important.
So it's live from the tabernacle because
I filmed it at the tabernacle theater in
atlanta,
Georgia.
And uh,
I think you could play this music.
It distracts me and it makes me
confused.
I don't know what to do a lie from the
tabernacles available drm free.
That means you could download it.
You can put it on whatever the fuck you
want.
You can copy it,
you can put it on your watch tv.
Watch on an ipad,
there's a bunch of different downloads
you can get to.
You can also stream it.
There's a lot of different options
available you can buy with paypal or
amazon.
It's only five bucks a louis c,
k style louis I think really sort of
changed the entire way the comedians are
going to be distributing their shows in
the future to self promote it and self
funded.
And that's what I did.
I paid for the entire filming of it all.
Um,
hired like a real director and my friend
anthony and his big company,
positive image video to do a great
professional job on it.
So I'm really proud of it.
It's a,
I think it's my favorite stuff of all
the stuff that I've ever done and it's
really exciting.
Um,
it's a,
an awesome time to be a comedian and I'm
a in my um,
my uh,
replenishing material phase right now.
So it's a really exciting.
I'm doing a lot of sets and having so
much fun coming up with new shit.
But the feedback's been amazing.
It's been the most positive feedback of
anything I've ever done online ever.
So I just want to thank you guys and
thanks to everybody that sends all the
cool tweets and the facebook messages
and all that shit.
I appreciate the fuck out of all,
but I can't thank everybody
individually.
One at a time.
But we know that you guys are enjoying
this show.
We know that you guys are enjoying the
standuP shows and all the other shit
that we do and we're very happy and
we're gonna keep doing it.
If you want to follow matt online,
you could follow him.
He is on twitter and uh,
his twitter handle is matt.
Then grin v e n g e r I n.
So it's m,
a t t e v e n g r I n d
what website do I do?
But I hardly use it,
but I would like to plug a charity book
I made.
Okay.
It's called poker with a purpose.
It's on amazon.
did you do that just to get checks?
no.
Say I do charity poker,
you know,
but I.
But I did.
I did give 100 percent of it to our
charity.
I didn't tell you.
That's beautiful.
That's all we got,
20 of the best poker players in the
world,
the writing it.
so that's cool.
Yeah.
And is it an instructional loaders?
Yeah,
so basically there's,
the way I did it was,
um,
I did uh,
like different facets of the game,
like I'm three betting you probably
won't understand the terms with three
different things of poker and I did
three people to do their opinion on it.
So you could choose whIch one you like
or incorporate whatever you like into.
Mostly it's just one person writing
about it,
like they know it to be fact.
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah.
And so all these different people put it
out and it's available
through amazon and it's just um,
since we were given this to.
I'm a green world.org
where they plant trees all throughout
the world.
Um,
so yeah,
we just,
it's 10 bucks is cheap and there's
amazing information and it's a strategy
book
that's beautiful.
And it's called poker with a purpose.
Correct.
And it's available on amazon.com.
Thanks again to a kerosene games for
promoting the podcast and go check out
belayed slinger.
Their newest video game,
their own,
their first actually they're working on
other ones,
but this is the first one.
Excellent.
Avail.
You son of a bitch,
you gotta a beta copy or is it a design
for a couple of?
It's a blade slingers available until
December 29th.
It's only ninety nine cents.
It's a two 99.
Normally.
So either way it's very reasonable.
Three bucks for an awesome video game
that you could play over and over again
until your dick falls off.
Alright,
so go get some sun and uh,
thanks.
Also to [inaudible] dot com.
Use the code name,
rogan.
That's r o g a n and save yourselF 10
percent off any and all supplements.
Alright,
you fucks.
Thank you matt for being on the podcast.
Pleasure.
Thank you.
Uh,
all you freak people out there in the,
in the wonderful world.
Oh my goodness.
Tomorrow we're going to have andrew dice
clay on.
He just texted me back.
These are the kinds of live updates.
Did you get on this fucking podcast?
So we'll see you tomorrow too.
Anything else?
I'll be at ice house chronicles friday
with a special guest that I can't
announce until thursday at midnight.
So tickets are on
sale@icehousecomedy.com.
It's going to be a podcast slash.
I'll tell you,
you can't say who it is,
but he might've been in a movie that
rhymes with super high.
AlRight fuckers.
Thanks a lot.
We'll see you tomorrow at 3:00
PM with andrew dice.
Clay.